BLM activist John Earl Sullivan has been
convicted for his role in incitement on
January 6 that is right this is a BLM
far-left activist and the funny thing
about it is we all know the media has uh
has in the past reported on his
activities we know that he was a
frequent um attendee and organizer for
many leftist rallies we know that's on
video he's cheering for what's happening
at the capital and uh now we've got the
corporate press saying he's an
anti-establishment
activist right because now they're
trying to deflect from the fact that
he's a black lives matter supporter and
that was basically what it was all about
he even said in the uh there's video of
him from the from that day where he's
saying I don't I'll be on anybody's side
if they're going to tear it all down Yad
Yad y so that's going to be uh uh
interesting how we see liberals in the
left respond to this considering well
for a long time a lot of conservatives
said there were anti there were leftists
there now it's one guy so we'll see but
we also got to talk about what's going
on with Tik Tok because this is a wild
story that's been going off since
yesterday Tik Tok has been promoting
videos where leftists say they read
Osama Bin Laden's letter to America and
that they believe he was correct I don't
think any of these people actually read
the thing because he's basically
lamenting how US foreign policy is
preventing Sharia law from taking hold
on the planet and how he wants all of
the West to come to Islam and uh I think
if they actually read maybe even like
the first parag where Bin Laden says
that you have to abandon fornication
homosexuality gambling and Usery they
might be like wait I don't know if we
agree with this guy but sure enough now
we're getting news that Tik Tok is going
to start banning all of these things so
it's a wild story we'll definitely talk
about that in a whole lot more before we
get started my friends head over to cast
brew.com and buy cast Brew Coffee why
it's the best cup of coffee you'll ever
have we got our limited edition rerise
with Roberto Jr available right now it's
our Halloween blend and uh we have the
the zombified chicken foot rising from
the earth so pick up that bag while you
still can because once they're gone
they're gone forever and we did we did
an initial run of 5,000 of these but of
course the everyone's favorite is rise
with Roberto Jr or light roast then
appalachion nights the dark roast and
stand your grounds we got K Cups when
you support Casper coffee are supporting
the work we do here but also our efforts
to build coffee shops and create
physical spaces in meat world where you
can talk to people share ideas and build
community also don't forget to head over
to
timcast.net considering our guests so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a whole lot more we got Dave Smith
what's up good to be back who are you uh
I am a uh stand-up comedian a podcaster
a soldier in the Ron Paul Army and a
destroyer of
lomers you had a debate with Laura
lommer the other day I did it was a it
was a fun time uh thank you uh shout out
to Zero Hedge uh for putting that thing
on uh it was a fun it was a fun time and
Zero Hedge is a cool publication so it
was cool to do it was like the first in
like a debate series that they were
launching so cool plus we got a Clint
Russell hanging out Clint Russell host
of liberty lockdown co-host of tower
gang co-host of the best political show
over on Rumble with Luc Kowski if you
can believe it can't be that good it's
it's pretty good it's it's actually it's
the best Sheamus I know potato man
doesn't believe me but it's true uh yeah
we're we just signed a deal with Rumble
we're very grateful for that and uh you
guys can actually check us out we're
going to have Jackson hle on this Sunday
6:00 don't miss it just search we are
change all one word on Rumble you'll
love it I don't know that lot guy sounds
foreign yeah he's actually he's uh yeah
interesting Polish person he is a yeah
he is a person of Pol they really are
not that I have issue I actually like
Polish people it's that's why I'm so
disappointed by him I actually really
love Polish food like Polish food it's
it's the best it's a lot of what they do
no Poland's fantastic well Sheamus is is
back I'm a cartoonist yes my name name
is Sheamus coglin also I've I've been on
Clint sh it is very very good actually
enjoyed it very much so I I will uh
concede that but that was before the new
co-host um I have a YouTube channel
called Freedom Tunes we create animated
cartoons about politics and the culture
War we released a cartoon today that I'm
super happy with everyone working on it
uh their their talents shined through
it's I think it's one of the funniest
videos we've made um and it's it's a a
parody of like those red pill guys who
will like find a beautiful young couple
on a datee and they be like what is are
you bringing to the table um and it's
it's a fun one I really good yeah yeah
Tim Tim got to see it while it was in
progress the other day so if you guys
want to check that out go over to uh
Freedom tunes on YouTube subscribe hit
the notification Bell I love you all I'm
looking forward to a good show I'm did
they record the uh debate between you
and Laura lomer yeah uh Zero Hedge put
it out on their uh Twitter uh or x uh uh
feed or whatever and uh I think Laura
Lumar put it out on her Rumble I'm going
to be moderating the next zeroedge
debate oh yeah so that'll be with I
don't know if it's official who it is
yet or what it's on so I'm not going to
mention it now but it's going to be
Trump vers Biden it's going to be in the
next couple weeks and as soon as I get
the green light that it's all confirmed
and everything I'll start telling
everybody what's what but keep an eye
open could you imagine Ian moering a
debate between those two like he would
just ask them questions they had no idea
what was going on they'd be like I don't
knowy did you guys have a moderator uh
yeah we had uh Adam uh from uh Patrick P
David's
uh he was and he he was great yeah I
love Adam he's a great guy uh and so
yeah he did he did a very good
job checking it out we got Serge
pressing the buttons yes I'm here uh
it's good to see you Dave and good to
see you too as well Clint uh and also to
see you too Sheamus I know I was were
seeing you last night didn't know you be
here today I know yeah it's great seeing
you as well man yeah cheers anyways
let's get into it guys here's a story
from the post-millennial far-left BLM
activist John Sullivan convicted on all
charges in the January 6 case solivan
said he was only at the capital to
document the event this is really
interesting because uh he's a prominent
M activist who was there during court
testimony he said he was only there to
document I was only observing I followed
the crowd I'm here to document San's
testimony was followed up by prosecutors
who played multiple videos of Sullivan
urging on the mob which included a self
de declaration to make Trump supporters
fish up I'm going to side with anyone
who is ready to rip this is down
Sullivan said in one video I brought my
megaphone to instigate is he said in
another video NBC news reports that
prosecutors portrayed SV as an
anti-establishment activist who had the
goal to burn it all down now I have to
wonder here's NBC news saying
anti-establishment activists sought to
incite Trump supporters on January 6 doj
argues but of course I want to make sure
we can bring up John Earl Sullivan's
Wikipedia page he's got one where they
mention he organized and participated in
protests relating to Black lives matter
though a few other BLM organizers
explicitly disavowed him I don't think
that matters that's what his his
ideology was they say he entered the
capital and accidentally broke a window
he repeatedly shouted encourage M to
fellow writers and they go on to
outright outline the things that uh he
he he he does and ultimately his claims
of being a journalist I believe CNN paid
him what did they pay him 50 Grand
something like that for his footage had
him on TV here's what's fascinating
here's why I think they're not calling
him farle for one there's absolutely NBC
News they're they're super biased but
we're talking about a federal federal
charge here do I'm I'm I'm curious
actually I believe it is DC right are
you going to convict a black lives
matter supporter on January 6 by telling
a jury that this guy was a black lives
matter supporter and so the strategy of
the prosecutors is if we go to the jury
and say it's BLM they acquit him and if
they acquit him then they got to quit
everybody well so so he's just being the
charges are being brought against him
right he hasn't been convicted convicted
on all oh he was convicted okay my
mistake okay and then do you does it say
anything about like what obviously
hasn't been sentenced yet but what type
of jail time he's looking at for this uh
well here's the interesting thing I mean
because breaking a window is what that
uh the proud boy or whatever got that
got him like 15 17 years or whatever it
was and they the argument was that they
were like well by breaking a window this
wasn't just oh you broke a government
window it was you created an opening for
a mob that would then be trying to
overthrow the government so I'm just
saying what cuz for the record whatever
this guy well whatever this guy was
armed on armed a knife okay they even
point out that he drew the knife in on
the house wait wait he he drew his knife
as Riders were trying to breach the
house floor well I didn't realized this
guy was a hero I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding that's a joke YouTube It's a
total joke and I don't mean that
literally but you know get my point
anyway um well I'm just saying what like
I because if they're going first off if
they're going to throw the book at this
guy in that way I still would think
that's insane as I do with all the
January 6 protesters what's really
interesting about this is the question
of which I don't know if it's clear
what is this guy hey I'm just so
anti-establishment I'm a burn it all
down when there's black lives matter
rally guy and I'm a burn it all down
when there's j6 type guys or is this
what I think a lot of the right Wingers
were more suspicious of initially after
january6 that this is somebody who's
trying to make the prot Trump movement
look bad by instigating all of them to
do something that then could be spun as
like yeah look how horrible the prot
Trump people are could be both cuz if
black lives matter was disavowing this
guy before the January 6 thing even went
off he might have been killed two birds
with one stone situation where he's like
youo I can f the government and I can
get all these people thrown in jail and
get them to commit crimes and then I can
you know do away with two she just
sounds like a radical that went too far
I don't know if you guys remember this
but prior to January of 2021 the left
was not shy about openly embracing
insurrectionist rhetoric I remember
during the BLM rights there were left
wiers who were saying all these
right-wing Hypocrites spend spent years
saying they have the Second Amendment to
rebel against tyranny and overthrow the
US government and now that the
government is just indiscriminately
killing unarmed black people which is of
course a lie but that's what they were
saying these right-wingers won't rise up
against this state and then as soon as
January uh 6th 2021 happens oh my gosh
Insurrection is the most serious problem
in this country and we need to call
these people Traders and throw them in
prison so it wouldn't surprise me that
you actually might have a left-wing
activist saying yeah I'll join with
these right- Wingers try to overthrow
the government or try to instigate
instigate right- wiers to
I want to crank this thing all the way
up to 11 right now if I may and just say
Civil War all everybody's been waiting I
haven't said it in a few months so I
feel like I'm it's it's due but no let
me explain I I don't literally mean to
say Civil War but I'd like for you guys
to give me your thoughts on the other
day we saw David deap testified this is
the guy who attacked Paul Pelosi in his
testimony he claimed that he was a
leftist who was radicalized by
right-wing conspiracy theories watching
YouTube of that he included me Glen
backck James Lindsay the toza made a
good point that this is a narrative
where they go to them and say they go to
these these people who are being charged
like the J Sixers and say blame Trump
blame the right and do this I think
there's a really simple reason why
that's the case you're in San Francisco
you are in The Bluest of blue and the
defense says to you listen you will not
win because you attacked Paul Pelosi
however the best sympathy you will get
is if you claimed you were radicalized
by the far right and that you you oh no
what if they done to me it's the evil
right that did it try and earn some SYM
in that way the reason why they're
arguing this guy in a federal case in DC
is anti-establishment and not farle once
again is for that exact same reason now
what happens is you are you are getting
through these high-profile cases in San
Francisco I'm seeing these people post
saying oh look James Lindsay Tim P
glenbeck oh they they radicalize this
guy it's a lie it's nonsense and but
it's creating that terrifying Boogeyman
it's creating that bifurcation if prose
prosecutors in high-profile cases are
keep are they're going to keep playing
this Narrative of Donald Trump is
radicalizing people to extremes anytime
someone commits an some kind of extreme
act even a BLM supporter they're going
to blame the far right or the quote
unquote far right they're creating a a
narrative that young people who are
entering the political space will
believe we live in this world so real
quick as an example it's a really it's a
really interesting point that you bring
up can I just say like because I think
that's such a good point and such an
interesting thing to to focus on because
like as a as a Libertarian um one of the
things that we talk about a lot is that
like look we we don't think government
should be in the business of kind of
micromanaging culture and things like
this but you also recognize that you
need other forces like you need kind of
a virtuous culture in order for that to
work and I think one of the things I've
been thinking this a lot like since all
these uh these insane indictments have
been coming down against Donald Trump
when you look at like kind of the
landscape of current day America you go
how could a guy like Donald Trump ever
get a fair trial I mean if you have have
a jury trial with Donald Trump whoever
the jury pool is it's like a 5050 shot
that they either think he is Jesus or
Satan and how could how could anyone who
has either one of those opinions ever be
an honest juror and I think kind of the
point you're making here is that like
look in the reality today of a modern
jury trial with the polarization of the
country and this white hot culture War
you almost yeah man if you're on trial
in San Francisco it's almost like the
only way to your defense is to try have
something that HS a leftwing sympathy
let me let me add to what you said you
said 5050 let's say 33 but no no no no
here's what I mean 33% are say Trump's
Hitler 33 are going to say Trump is good
and 33 are going to say holy crap I
better side with the left otherwise
antifa is going to sh to my house death
fair enough but but it's an interesting
point right because people who were uh
charged in relationship to January 6th
or because of activities they engage in
on January 6th are tried in Washington
DC as if that's a jur of their peers I'm
sorry if you came from Arkansas DC
leftists are that's not a jury of your
peers that's
people exactly people with a specific
political bias who hate you in your way
of life hold on I mean think about what
you're saying here other Americans are
your enemies oh boy so so when I'm not
other Americans people in Washington DC
let's be clear about this but I get it
but like the the the the genuine
sentiment is if you are from look I
brought this up yesterday when we were
talking about the thing we had a legal
issue against the major corporation and
my lawyer said okay well if you sue in
California or New New York you'll lose
the the Democrat judge is already going
to hate you Tim pool and outside of that
they're going to be way more Pro
corporate and they're not going to care
about your rights you sue in West
Virginia you're going to win overnight
why well you're in West Virginia they
like you Tim poool and I'm like is that
really all that it is
yes selecting the proper venue is the is
like one of the most important things
especially today if not the most
important thing I have I have a bit of a
different angle on this I think that the
uh the the real concern that I have is
that you have these commentators that
are being categorized like your my
friend Tim here along with James Lindsay
and others that they're trying to kind
of lay out the groundwork for the
stochastic terrorism argument where
you're being uh you know pushed into
radicalism by people who are just
speaking freely and then you're now in
some in some way uh what's it what's the
word excc uh where where basically your
your your personal responsibility is
removed because you've been inspired by
this radical Tim P or Alex Jones or
whatever and it just it really because
of the where we're at that's a real
thing and look they've come at you
before with that wasn't what was the
other that Young Turks uh chick tried to
like come at you about how uh some
shooter liked one of your videos or
something like that not Young Turks I'm
sorry my
mistake that was the guy in Texas who uh
on his Facebook had posted four
screenshots of one episode and one
specific portion of one episode and it
actually showed wasn't a subscriber
which it's such a crazy thing because
when you have a show like look like you
have a show like with this size audience
which you've built up a very big
platform here the idea that any one
person who one time liked one clip on
this you're now on the it's literally
it's almost on the level of like well
this this Mass shooter watched Friends I
mean well I think I think obviously Ross
and Rachel are the reason why he shot up
that but but the other thing about it
that's crazy is that that radicalized me
when you yeah I I'll tell you she's the
one it was on that show she was the one
but like if you actually kind of live in
this world of like I do consider myself
to be a radical politically speaking I'm
pretty radically outside of what the
current status quo is but when you're in
this world it's kind of uh my my good
friend Michael malice good friend of the
show he used to always say and I really
loved this uh when he would go I hope
left wiers understand that the NRA are
the moderates on
CU it really is like if you're not in
that world I know they painted as like
that's like the crazy extreme that's the
NRA is up there like all we need to do
is enforce existing gun laws and you're
like wow that's so extreme and you're
like extreme contition is like shell not
infringe yes like but the point is that
if you're actually talking about a
radical show like a show and I'm not
even not radical in the way I am I'm
radically like nonviolent and peaceful
if you were talking about a show that
was going to amp you up to go like
murder people
this is not that show there's crazy
people out there on the internet and
this is not that real quick question do
you think individual citizens have the
right to keep and bear biological
weapons
well we're getting a little out there
with biological weapons i' say down univ
I say well it depends on what the
biological weapon is how it's I mean uh
I it depends on exactly what your
definition of that is I draw my line at
nukes I uh no I'm just kidding uh well
you no look I think if you were to have
this's a serious question abely I will
say unequivocally the Constitution uh
guarantees our right to keep in bare
arms it doesn't Define what arms are
private citizens to this day own nuclear
weapons through their corporations and
back then owned warships nothing's
changed yeah so right now to this day
it's not even controversial to say
except in the in these podcasts liberals
get shocked that I would say this and
I'm like do you think Ron is a
government operation yes no look so in
that case you're absolutely right there
could be an argument made that if you
were uh if you were possessing a
chemical weapon and were keeping them
like in a in a very risky way that could
hurt a lot of other people then you
should be maybe liable for the fact that
you're putting other people at risk but
in theory in theory I would tend to
agree with you this is the argument they
make about proper gun storage and stuff
like this like you can only have a gun
if it's separate from the ammo and in
your trunk and not your you know not in
the same yeah so then the question is
where you do draw the line but at the
same point if you had a gun that you
left out that the difference between
like a nuke or or chemical weapons and a
gun is that a nuke if you're just
keeping it in a way where it could just
detonate at any moment is actually a
threat to other people whereas a gun
someone actually has to pick it up and
point the trigger and shoot anyway I'm
all for no no restrictions brandishing a
weapon if you're like waving it around
at people on wrongly so you could you
could think maybe there's don't try to
out Anarchist
me I'm not going to lose this I will I
will say let me just say real quick I I
I do agree with the sentiment obviously
I don't want the government regulating
any Weaponry that I can own however I go
the opposite direction where I say uh
Humanity ought to be working towards
nuclear disarmament broadly speaking so
I'm not interested in having civilians
have them I'm more interested in getting
the federal government to have far less
the goal should be to disarm Federal
governments that should be the goal yes
I think every every person on the planet
should have a a nuke perhaps a MV with
you know a 12 Warhead MV and because a
nuclear armed individual an individually
nuclear armed Society is in is a very
polite I'm kidding I am kidding
extraordinarily polite or glowing either
way it's a have you read John John lot's
book more nukes less crime it's uh it's
good a lot of good stats in there anyway
what were we talking about before I
decided to ask about that uh Janu we
were talking about the courts and how
the courts have basically turned into if
you're in a conservative District you
know what a leftist is going to get a
fair trial not as as Fair as like it's
hard to say fair fair um a leftist in a
conservative district is going to get a
decent trial and trial is going to get T
feathered strung for for jay walking or
farting Donald Trump could fart in
public and they're going to get him on
some nonsense and and lock him up the
truth the truth is that that LE is Dogma
is is so much a prerequisite for all of
Academia at this point if you if you
have to rely on any Institution for your
freedom you're in a lot of trouble at
this point yeah politically in in
Academia obviously now in the Judiciary
as well it it's not getting any better
either because they have had a hundred
years of infiltration into these
uh you know mind creation institutions
so yeah we're we have an uphill battle I
think the like the only caveat and I
agree with what you're saying Tim I
think there is there there is a point
there that it's not equal kind of on on
both sides but I guess part of the
difference there too is that look there
is let's say in right-wing or red
America I think there is a tremendous
amount and I would argue justifiably but
a tremendous amount of like resentment
towards say the political establishment
the de particularly the Democratic party
establishment so the the thing is I
don't I don't know that in this moment
of this hot culture War I don't know
that Hillary Clinton could get a fair
trial in rural Alabama but the thing is
that Hillary Clinton has never going to
face charges in rural Alabama right like
the the federal government or different
state governments or different like if
there were some like conservative
Finance or who's financing you know
conservative prosecutors never
Hinton where Donald will Beal New York
City Wasington DC and so that that is a
part of the asymmetry also is that the
entire like ruling base of the
establishment is on one side of you know
people say like oh the red pill is that
people who have information that would
lead to the arrest of Hillary Clinton
die actually the red pill is no amount
of information will ever lead to the
arrest of Hillary Clinton there is
nothing you could show anybody
day in cour yeah that's a big cope that
you think at the end of this you know
whatever the Q andon crazy
is Jack Kennedy is coming back Roseanne
has a standing bet with Michael malice
two of them one is that there will not
be an election so we're looking forward
to that and that there will be military
tribunals by the end of the year which I
I don't know if if she talking about
this year or what but uh you know we'll
see she has right about everything let's
but but you know to be honest she made a
good point though cuz I asked her to
clarify on this I said are you saying we
all just skip election day the TV says
no elections or are you saying that
something changes the election
fundamentally to the point where it's a
sham like North Korea's elections if
that's the case we didn't have an
election in 2020 well or 2016 look I'll
say as and I say this uh disclaimer I
love Roseanne I consider her like a
comedy icon and every time I've met her
I'm giddy in the room that I'm even in
her presence and she's just hilarious
and so great but perhaps a little bit
more of a serious voice on this uh topic
is Colonel Douglas McGregor yeah who
also said he is I don't know exact
exactly what he said but he basically
said that he is very concerned that
there will not be a democratic election
in 2024 now I'd like to hope he's he's
wrong about that um he wasn't
wrong can can we break down what does
that mean does that mean yeah and this
is the important question we had with
Rosanne does that mean there's no
polling stations the TV just says you're
not voting or does it mean it's going to
be uh Donald Trump removed from the
ballot and then 75 million people feel
like they're not allowed to vote at all
because of this well I don't know I mean
I have no idea it's not my prediction
but I think what uh if I remember
correctly this was on Patrick B David
show he said this uh Colonel Douglas
McGregor that is who's been right about
a lot of stuff over the last 20 years
and um I think he was basically saying
that some type of emergency is going to
be declared uh and that that is going to
it's going to be used as an excuse to
postpone inde definitely the next
election now again I'm not claiming this
is going to happen but I will say that
it if that sounds crazy to you just take
a step back look at the last three and a
half years in America and go look a lot
of things sound the idea of lockdowns
would have sounded really crazy in
2019 and you know that happened if you
talk to yourself from 2014 you were like
all right so here's what's going to
happen Donald Trump's going to be
elected president and then the Deep
State's going to try to unseat Donald
Trump when he's the president of the
United States cuz he's trying to
dismantle the industrial military
complex and get us out of all of these
Foreign Wars and then what's going to
happen is there's going to be a virus
that was created through research funded
by the United States that'll be released
and everyone's going to be locked in
their homes and the economy's going to
crash and we're going to have rampant
inflation and then people are going to
be debating whether the election was
still You' be like what are you talking
but also the FBI and the CIA will be
working against Donald Trump the entire
time they'll be lying to him about troop
counts in Syria we'll have a bunch of
different fronts for nuclear for World
War I yeah it's this is all going to
happen in the next five years let me
pull this up so let me pull this up we
have this from Zero Hedge I don't think
we'll ever get to the 2024 election
Colonel Douglas McGregor retired warns
uh uh and that's this is the gist of it
uh so let's see I I think oh I think
that's does he usually make bombastic
claims he's on the pbd podcast no no no
this is not he is not like uh he's not
the type of guy to just say wild things
to get a reaction this is a serious guy
this was like a highly decorated colonel
in the military he was mcmaster's boss
at one point in the military and then
just like he kind of turned against all
of the wars I believe he drew up the for
battle with Russia if we were to ever go
to war with the let this so they want
they first in the zero article break
down who he is they say bet David laid
out how he thinks 2024 will play out he
says Nome will go around defending Biden
selling Biden's record have him
constantly attack to santis if Biden
doesn't step down have mainstream media
attack him once Jill notices the attacks
have a private meeting with Biden
sharing strategy to save face multiple
documentary showing him as a modern FDR
massive Simon and chuster book deal
defend its Legacy step five choose one
of the few options to step down due to
health Jill and I prayed about it we've
we we fixed everything Trump broke we're
out step six is in order to prevent
kamla from backstabbing let her become
the first female president for a split
second then step down divide is s in
Trump Newsome becomes 47 to step8 y y in
response to this McGregor went dark
Beginning by noting that first of all I
think it's brilliant and I think that if
we are we're living in a linear World in
other words when one event follows the
next logically you're absolutely right
but uh but I don't think we'll ever get
to the 2024 election I think things are
going to implode in Washington before or
then from there it gets more ominous now
uh uh I don't I don't know that I
disagree and one of the reasons is which
we'll get into it a little bit later is
is Tik Tock pushing the Osama bin L
Osama Bin Laden letter to America and
having a bunch of genz leftists claim
that Osama was correct again we'll talk
about that in a moment but I'm just
saying the the political divide in this
country is so psychotic right now yeah
to the point where like we already
mentioned if you're being criminally
charged in a liberal District your best
is to say Trump made you do it no matter
what it is shoplifting I was watching
this video about Donald Trump and he
told me to do it please help help I'm a
victim of of the guy you hate I listen
dude I'll say still to this day and
you've Tim you've done some incredible
things in in your career but if I had to
pick still to this day what I'd say I
think your greatest moment was was still
Jack dorsy Rogan with the Rog because it
was just such an incredible thing it
everything lined up where like first if
you remember uh that Jack dorsy went on
Rogan and they didn't have a very
confrontational argument and it's
literally to this day the only Joe Rogan
Experience episode where I ever saw like
Joe's audience really upset with him and
and as great and this is a credit to Joe
who you know full disclosure is a friend
of mine but a credit to him is he was
like okay I hear you let's like run that
back with someone who's critical of that
but you had the point to them and people
could accuse you of being hyperbolic
people accuse me of kind of the same
thing um but you had that moment to them
where you were like I I don't remember
your exact words but you were like you
guys don't realize what you're playing
with here like you don't realize the
game you're playing and you're like I'm
getting a van and like going to be
bringing and like I'm like really
concerned about like you provoking a
Civil War in this country and okay it's
not like we've had a civil war exactly
since then but look we are we know we're
all flirting with it and this is a real
thing that when people make these kind
of dire warnings I understand it's easy
to go Ah that's kind of crazy but look
around at this country man we are
flirting with a lot of very insane
possibilities time travel test go back
to what was it was it 2018 or 2019 uh
when I was on with with Jack dorsy V and
it might have been 2019 2018 it was 19
it might was it 19 yeah go back to that
year and tell people I if I went back
and everything I said was was vague
predictive like this country is headed
towards Civil War I'm getting a van I'm
building a van with solar power getting
ready to bug the F out and they're
laughing like haha yeah yeah yeah right
now go back and say since then the for
the first time ever a sitting president
has been indicted in multiple
jurisdictions January 6 just January 6
alone I had uh Ryan long came here on
the show love Ryan fantastic think one
one of the first things he says when The
Show Goes live is he goes Tim you told
me there was going to be a Civil War
what happened I thought you you you were
getting me all hyped up I was really
worried when I left and then I said a
thousand Trump supporters stormed into
the capital and disrupted the Electoral
College of vote count anyway oh well I
mean and even the the Riots of 2020 I
mean the fact that we had the longest
sustained riots causing billions of
dollars of property destruction that
same year so this is or the the so this
this is the important thing to
understand is um you know going back to
something like that debate what we're
seeing with Twitter we're seeing uh uh
the the hyperpolarization of the of of
Twitter the rules they were creating the
narratives they were swinging and the
bifurcation in American culture and
that's the point I was making like you
guys keep doing this yeah you are
creating two distinct universes and what
I could see at the time and what I can
see now is like a blur it's like when
you if anybody wears glasses you know
exactly what I mean your glasses are off
and you see a strange shape in front of
you you can't exactly Define it but
you're like there is a person walking
towards me right now you put your
glasses on you can see it clearly if I
had glasses I could see the future but
I'm saying what we're witnessing right
now I as Phil leonti says what's the
off-ramp if if we're now seeing in these
in these in these January 6
cases confess and say Donald Trump made
you do it or you're done we're seeing
Enrique too getting 20 years he wasn't
even there but more importantly since
that point we've had the Summer of Love
rights the worst RS in 50 years 30 plus
deaths we've had a guy Gunn down in the
street in Portland we've had multiple
autonomous zones I can't even begin to
stress how we've normalized this go back
then and say it what if I said to Jack
dorsy and vti very specifically within
the next year or year and a half there
will be far-left extremists who occupy
City centers with rifles and kill people
who oppose them they'd say you're nuts
and it happened and now we're just like
oh that happened are we not even shocked
that's going on so so exactly and so the
okay the point that I'm trying to make
here is that it okay like imagine I
don't know what the analogy exactly
would be but so imagine um you go you
know you were in a business and you were
talking to the other like stockholders
and you go I think this business is in
is in real trouble I think we're going
to be out of business next year and then
next year you're not out of business but
your stock is down 90% And they went see
you're wrong we weren't out of business
okay fine so I'm not saying yeah
technically speaking maybe you weren't
out of maybe it wasn't a civil war maybe
we weren't out of business but still at
least grant that there was like a lot
accurate to this prediction and that's
my point about by the way just tying
this back to the not being elections
maybe that's not exactly right maybe
Colonel Douglas McGregor is is not word
for word right about this but there
still might be much like with your
prediction like some real insight into
one I'll give you I'll give you the
poent the
potentiality October 2024 a single state
Secretary of State decides Donald Trump
is ineligible based on the 14th
Amendment as they've interpreted it and
so they remove his name from the ballots
immediately and we're when we're 3 weeks
out or whatever from the election so
early voting is happening immediately
you get the Trump team of all the
conservatives everyone filing emergency
notices saying we need an injunction on
this immediately and then the state says
okay we'll see you in court they go to
court by December there's a ruling yeah
guys you can't keep Trump off the ballot
oh the election's over Trump wasn't on
the ballot we've already seen in
Michigan and Minnesota they've said no
to this but the issue would be they're
look we saw this in Arizona and so I'm
not basing this off of nothing in
Arizona the wrong balls were printed on
the wrong paper so the machines didn't
work
I guarantee you I shouldn't say that
because I can't actually guarantee you
but I would tell you this right now I
will I would bet a substantial amount of
money that in 2024 we will see similar
voting machine errors on par with a
misprint that results in jurisdictions
failing it may listen if we hear about
100 jurisdictions and it totals maybe a
single percentage point that this
happened no one will accept it no matter
which side it ends up being left if if
it happens to Trump if it happens to
anybody else I knew some I don't think
well the truth is that government is a
faith-based
system and that's that's especially true
for democracy the whole thing is kind of
ryant on this it's all a religion in a
way it's all like you believe in it we
believe in look government is a religion
in in every sense of the word right you
it has its kind of like um sacraments
and its rituals and its nobility
cows it has its blasphemy the things
you're not allowed to say right it has
all of this and also you know much like
religion um and I I say this is someone
who believes in God so don't take this
the wrong way but it is so picture this
like the religion you don't believe in
not the religion you do believe in okay
so if you're religious every other
religion not your one uh but also it
doesn't exist like government itself
doesn't exist it's an idea that's in
your head and that idea almost gone well
right but it's that's the point is that
if it's not in your head then it's not
you know there's no there isn't
government there's buildings and there's
men with guns and who will enforce the
politicians wills and there's titles
that we made up you know Senator
Governor president but none of that is
objective reality this is an idea that
we all buy into and so when you have
something like
330 million people in a nation and then
however what is it 140 million voters or
something like in that ballpark and they
were all recording all of their votes
one day yeah now obviously it could be a
much better system than we have here but
it requires to some degree a leap of
faith for people to just say I believe
in this system and nobody has that in
the united very few people losing our
religion I think it's fair to say that
2012 was the last election I'm not
saying 100% it is true I'm saying it's
fair to say in that 2016 was disputed by
the left as fraudulent because Russia
interfered they even believe they
flipped votes etc etc 2020 the Trump
supporter said the same thing of the
Democrats I don't care who you think is
right or wrong you're allowed to think
you're right you're allowed to think
other people are wrong the point is we
have now had two elections where both
sides have accused each other of very
dramatic serious treason yes and the
point is that that it's almost like if
you believe it then you're right because
the point I'm making about saying it's
like a religion again I I really just to
be clear I'm not trying to knock the
idea of religion I'm saying like some of
the things that I think are the most
beautiful ideas and institutions in the
world think marriage is amongst the most
beautiful institutions in the world but
in a marriage if either the husband or
the wife doesn't believe in it anymore
then they're right right there there is
no there is no objective thing there
it's like if you don't believe it it
like then you you're right then you're
not in this anymore it almost requires
both of you to believe in this thing
that it's
real but I
Doone that you can get into how you trap
your wife in the the basement after this
but I'm just saying I'm saying my wife
is free to leave anytime she wants to
and she doesn't want to leave it's not
Catholic though right so but you're not
baptized yeah well it's it's a different
situation but my point is but you don't
believe in the concept of like
sacramental marriage or that you're like
actually Bound in a way where you can't
leave I'm not saying that you're not I'm
saying you can believe that you're bound
in that way and I do believe that I yes
I believe that I've made a commitment to
my wife that I said in front of our
families and in front of God and that I
will till death do us part uh and yes I
believe that but if I stop believing
that it doesn't exist anymore that's my
point it's it requires the belief in
that otherwise it's over and so in a
sense even though it is completely
ridiculous for the the left half of
America to say that Vladimir Putin
overthrew the government in 2016 when he
installed Trump them believing that in
itself changes the whole dynamics of
politics and the same thing for Trump
supporters who believe the election was
stolen in 2020 now I'm not saying it
wasn't or it was I'm just saying once
you believe that we're not playing the
same game anymore you but you're putting
on like the lens of what you think is
right and wrong I'm saying forget what
you think is right or wrong I'm saying
if your wife stops believing that she
has she's going to act as if she's not
married you're in a different game
you're in a different game now cly
differentation and so that's what we're
dealing with in America today yeah no my
point is simply to say that I I agree
with some of what you're saying and I
think ultimately we would just disagree
like the moral questions of how you're
sort of formulating the analogy the way
I understand it is I believe obviously
in the the tress of my faith I also
believe there are such things as false
religions I think anytime you have a
false idol you have a false religion and
government has become an idol for many
people especially people in government
they really do see themselves as the
highest moral Authority even fouchi is
saying something like I am the science I
mean that is a mocker of Christ I am the
way I am the truth I am the life fouchi
is saying he is truth itself and they
also say that science is the way and the
life they have this insane kind of
scientist system of thought built up
where anyone who calls themselves an
expert is now entitled to tell you
exactly how how to live your life they
have the fullness of the truth so I I
totally agree that there are parallels
here with with um false religions
rothbart actually talked about this in
anatomy of the state that once faith in
the state declines they would replace it
with a technocracy or scientism it's
exactly what we've seen we that they're
basically evolving naturally but I I
want to point uh I want to go back to a
point from a minute ago when you were
talking about uh you know sitting down
with Jack DOR on on Rogan the whole
reason that oh first off you didn't know
at the time but thanks to Elon Musk
acquisition and the Twitter leagues we
now know that much of those policies in
the terms of service modification as
well as the moderation policy shifts
were being dictated by a multitude of
three-letter agencies now let's back up
a little bit further the whole reason
that that they felt genuinely righteous
in in modifying these things even if you
discount the FBI interference and
everything else was because they felt
genuinely that Donald Trump had had the
election stolen because of Russian
interference that was also the state
that had planted those seeds all
fictitious Hillary Clinton the steel
dossier all AE so you have this entire
censorship apparatus that is being ruled
out and you have useful idiots that are
actually propagating it based off of
deception that is all a CIA plan from
the get-go now now let's just to just to
add to what you said they are they
genuinely believe Trump stole the
election he's a he's a Putin asset so he
must be stopped but that narrative
itself was created by them and this is
why I have long described Twitter as
Jack dorsy hooking his own sewer system
into his own mouth dorsy created Twitter
with a team and everybody's sharing
ideas crackpot psychotic refu is
splattered all over the place on Twitter
and Jack dorsy decides I'm going to take
that funnel and shove it down my throat
and starts consuming it he then adopts
the ideology of chaos listen this is the
important thing the the uh Tik Tock
story uh uh about gen Z believing Bin
Laden was correct because they read his
letter proves my point there's no way
they actually read his letter if they
did it's all anti-lgbt they didn't
actually read it they're simply saying
they agree with it because they're
seeing other people say it Jack dorsy
saw the same Trends decided to abide by
them without knowing what he was talking
about and that's what the left is and he
built rules around it which helped
propagate the very cult all right before
we get into the the Osama Bin Laden
letter but just one thing on on that
like and I don't completely disagree
with you but there is kind of like
another element into this which is that
look if you look at the state of social
media from uh pre
2016 it was just a different world and
I'm not saying that nobody ever got like
banned or kicked off there were very
rare instances where people would go
really really far like when people would
actually be like advocating like you
know Nazism and stuff like that where
they would get banned but it was very
rare I mean I remember back in the days
and of the Wild Wild West and I say that
in the best possible sense of the term
as a Libertarian love the Wild Wild West
uh but that it was a you could kind of
say whatever you wanted to without any
fear that like oh I better watch myself
or I bet I'm and of course it was
because all of the incentives lined up
for social media companies to not want
to kick people off because it was real
competition still well look the whole
thing is they you to be on their site
they don't want to kick you off but so
so let me give you the the quick finish
your thought so I can well so my point
is that the rise of Donald Trump who
really tweeted his way to the presidency
and tweeted his way to the presidency
when the entire establishment said this
guy is not allowed to win and ended up
winning and used Twitter to drive the
entire news cycle through the entire uh
uh uh election once he won the the all
of the powerful people people in
government in the media class they
couldn't simply accept that oh he had a
message that resonated with the people
even though we told you there was no way
this message would resonate with the
people and we couldn't accept that
Hillary Clinton turns out to just be a
horrifically corrupt unlikable awful
human being and but this was I'm just
saying this actually happened that they
hauled all of the heads of uh the big
social media the big tech companies in
front of Congress and explicitly in
front of everybody threatened them with
violence you know they threatened them
with we will regulate your the reason
Trump won is because of disinformation
and Russian interference and you better
do something about that or else ofat
that was that was a factor in what
happened let me give you the quick
rundown um of what social media started
as social media website post what you
want to post people did eventually too
many people are posting Facebook says
people their feeds are cluttered up
reverse chronological isn't working we
need them to stay on the website
algorithm were were created algorithms
will deliver to you content we think you
like better many of them failed the
early algorithms of YouTube were if it
gets more clicks show it more what
happened every thumbnail became women in
bikinis I'm dead serious right what ends
up happening then is a bunch of
companies started emerging Huffington
Post one of the first all of a sudden
they're getting massive traffic
everyone's clicking their articles they
can read the news now not through a
newspaper and comment on these stories
what ends up happening through the
algorithms Facebook says share the links
that get the most clicks what happens
then what gets the most clicks police
brutality videos things that in in uh
make people angry get the most clicks
overnight in the early 2010s we end up
seeing my favorite example is mike.com
do you guys know that started as a Ron
Paul Pro Ron Paul website yeah you told
me about it mike.com started as
libertarian Pro Ron Paul and with a
component of anti- police brutality
because Libertarians were very into this
eventually however Mike becomes social
justice why it was getting more clicks
to go beyond police brutality this whole
machine's always been in play so we can
say pre- 2016 it was a different story
no no no no you were just and you were
walking into the building you just
didn't see the bowels I'm deep so I
don't I I don't deny that and I think
there is part of this that just was an
organic force of like how can we get
more clicks and more clicks and more
clicks but I am saying that like there
there was a government intervention and
obviously we know from all of like the
Twitter files and all of that stuff now
that there was massive like government
intervention that certainly put their
thumb on this scale and said and
particularly I'm not just saying about
the clickbait stuff I'm more talking
about like the tech censorship stuff
where they really did crack down on
these companies and insist that you like
censor dissenting voices and often times
well let me just say and often times it
was dissenting voices who were getting
tons of clicks and what you need to
understand is the people working for the
Intel agencies are not like it's a
30-year-old guy in 20 in 2005 who is now
a 40-year-old guy in 2015 who went who
oh we better censor this it is in 2015
them hiring a new 30-year-old who's been
indoctrinated for 10 years by the refu
machine a 10-year-old a kid born in 2000
gets on the internet gets on Facebook
for the first time in 2010 and what does
he see on Facebook literally nothing but
police brutality videos the the police
brutality was so ubiquitous on Facebook
that one of there was a website
dedicated to nothing but police
brutality videos in the top 500 Global
websites making millions of dollars
you're 10 years old you get on Facebook
and it's all you see yeah for the next
four or five years in your formative
years the only thing you see guess what
they're BLM activists now now you have
critical race theorists and marxists now
imagine this imagine you're already 10
years old in in 2000 and you're just
starting to get on the internet by the
time you're 15 you're being inundated
with this stuff 10 years later you're 25
you're now working in these Intel
agencies you're you're out of college
you're interning this is what we saw
with budlight I predicted this I said
I'm willing to bet it's going to turn
out I was talking to Vi about this it's
a young Millennial marketing person who
is just brought on and is Ros risen in
the ranks and is now trying to push
their crackpot garbage into the machine
what did it turn out to be exactly that
a millennial woman who said let's do
wokeness and then burn the company to
the ground cuz we don't want these frat
boy customers that buy you know millions
of cans of our every year why why are we
seeing 16-year-olds in San Francisco
marching through the hallways chanting
from The River To The Sea do you
genuinely think these kids know anything
about Israel Palestine no they've been
indoctrinated by their by their schools
let's let's get let's let's go to it
baby it's not just their SCH one point
about that after we jump to the next
story point we can make well I just want
to say you mentioned their brainwashed
by their schools that's that's certainly
true in part um I I had the privilege of
speaking to Dr George bar on my podcast
and he's done research on what tends to
form the beliefs of the youth in America
and what he found is that like without a
close second media is basically what
shapes their opinions when you look at
schools you look at
church
it's all of things media what they're
consing onion
basally so so here let me let me pul
this story from the Daily Mail we got a
lot of stuff to uh Point points to make
Tik Tok will scrub videos of anti-israel
gen zers fawning over Bin Laden's vial
2002 letter to America because it
clearly violates our rules on supporting
any form of terrorism I want to show you
this image in this image can you switch
over Serge it says ticktockers are now
justif this from Libs of Tik Tok the
9/11 attacks and praising Bin Laden
because he was just the resistance this
man in in one of his videos it it says
2011 me finding out we got him and he's
cheering then it switches to this
reading his letter to America knowing he
was right full stop the point Tik Tock
is doing what we have seen social media
companies do quite a bit of they are
creating a trend and these people have
not actually read Bin Laden's letter not
even a single word of it and I know for
a fact I think any sane person can see
that what they're doing is instead oh
this guy got a million views by saying
that let me make the same video and get
a million views there's there's
definitely a lot of that I don't I don't
think it's a lot there's no way woke
leftists read a letter saying ban
homosexuality and then said he was right
so you're telling me that you don't
believe in woke leftists ability to
contradict themselves and like I'm
saying drop of a I'm saying that some of
these posts that are prominent come from
Muslim activists who are saying look he
was right and they do you see the video
where uh it was it was billboard Chris
and the antifa guy goes up to two Muslim
women and says he's trying to stop kids
from being trans and and they're like we
agree what happens then is because
people are getting millions of views
these other young people are like I want
to get millions of views and just make a
a fake video claiming they read the
letter they did not I'm not denying that
that I'm sure there are people who are
doing that but I'm just but I'm just
making the point they can they can
contradict themselves but I will not no
but I mean in the most blatant way they
they can themselves no I mean i' I've
seen it over and over again where the
woke leftists can literally sit here and
say like um they go there's no such
thing as gender and also I knew I was in
the wrong gender from the moment I was
born cuz it's in my brain and these are
the completely contradictory ideas we
had Lance from the surfs on the show who
said you can get abortion whenever you
want then he said but but a woman can't
do meth because it intentionally kills
the baby right we've seen these things
and everybody love that clip but I do
not believe you can take a statement ban
homosexuality put it in front of any
leftist and say would you agree with
this I think if they would not agree
with well look I the the the issue here
always is and I've I've been struggling
with this myself over the last uh say
month or whatever is that I think when
there is uh when there is a reasonable
point to be made and then it's put into
the hands of left wiers to make that
Reon reasonable point they will make it
in the worst way possible um so I think
that what's going on obviously this has
to do with the context of what's
happening with Israel and and Gaza right
now right like that's that's the part of
the reason why this is going so
16-year-olds chanting from the river to
the sea is why they're saying Bin Laden
was right they don't know anything about
what they're talking I come listen I'm
not defending leftwing 16-year-olds
they're going to say a lot of stupid
things but this is the point I think
that but I think what the what what the
point should be so I'm I'm with you
completely
leftwing 16-year-olds are stupid that's
not that's my my point is it is not just
16-year-olds we have 37y old Millennials
who are indoctrinated in the exact same
way they're also no also yes no sure
sure but listen these are people in the
intelligence agencies how old is vindman
these are people who are at the CIA who
are removing Donald Trump from the
presidency because they believe this
crackpot BS I mean I think I think the
people I think the people in the
intelligence agencies even the ones who
are removing uh are trying to remove
Donald Trump are much more on board with
Israel than against Israel but I would
say this look I think the konel of Truth
here and what a lot of these guys just
are trying to get at but do a horrible
job of of getting at it is that look in
Ben Laden's letter to America obviously
he's an islamist and he's saying all
types of crazy things that a lot of us
don't agree with well Sheamus maybe
mostly but the rest of us don't agree
with that uh but there are stated
grievances in this letter that you have
to admit okay he probably has a legit
grievance here you understand why this
would be why this would be fertile
ground for Recruitment and why almost
any people would probably resent this if
this was happen let me read the first
one as for the first question why are we
fighting and opposing you the answer is
very simple number one with a bullet
because you attacked us and continue to
attack us that's that's the first thing
he says so like no no no no no full stop
full stop I I am I'm sorry dude I I I
reject this outright you can't just read
a sentence I can read I've read the
whole thing Tim I know exactly what he
say so you need to understand what
attack us means and he outlines very
clearly in the entire second half
attacking us means stopping Sharia Islam
from taking over the world yes he also
includes 1.5 million kids that that
starve in Iraq because of sanction
regime you can't discount that either my
point is it's like a guy saying I I am I
am attacking you because you kicked my
dog and we're like wow you kicked his
dog why and he goes because I was trying
to to eat it and you're like well wait
wait hold on this so what's happening is
you got a lot of these leftists and
Glenn Greenwald did this too Bin Laden
was mad about US foreign policy Bin
Laden was mad about US foreign policy
imposing it's it's a western Viewpoint
and preventing Islam it's all in his
well look okay again there's no question
he's a radical islamist and that's all
that's that's uh all throughout the
letter you can can see that there but I
think that the issue is that so these
left wiers take it in this Direction
that's like well he was right and you're
like no of course that's not the
conclusion the conclusion is he was an
insane mad man who's obviously like an e
he's obviously an evil figure there's no
getting around that the point is that
obviously within this islamist rhetoric
there are also these grievances of and
look the that you have attacked us that
you have bases in our holy land that you
uh you prop brutal dictators in our
region that you support the Israelis who
are are are have ethnically CLE uh
cleansed the Palestinians that you uh
and then of course the sanctions
campaign against the Iraqis and all the
kids who died now I'm not saying
obviously his wishes his wishes are that
they would be under Sharia law and and
Muslim control but it's still here's the
thing right when it since uh from 911
and the years these have slowed down a
little bit but for at least 15 years
afterward the FBI did all of these um
you know sting operations what they what
are really entament operations where
they claim we foiled another terrorist
plot but then you find out that they
created the whole thing every time they
did it every time they did it go look at
how they recruited the person listen
they never read them the Quran they
always said how do you feel about us
foreign policy in the Muslim world the
point shouldn't be that Osama Bin
Laden's a good guy the point should be
that this is why he was able to recruit
people who were willing to go blow
themselves up and and let me point this
out when Glenn Greenwald let me pull up
Glenn greenwald's tweet says his three
main grievances are us sanctions on Iraq
that killed the hundreds of thousands of
Iraqi children two US support for
Israeli violence and three US troops on
sacred Saudi land that is this is what
pisses me off that is I'll tell you what
that is that's black lives matter that
is Michael Brown that is BLM saying they
shot and killed Michael Brown that's why
we're mad that's why we're rioting and
then you go well hold on there a minute
Michael Brown robbed a liquor store and
then attacked the cop okay so if if
you're really saying you're mad that he
was shot what you're actually saying is
your intention is to be able to freely
and willfully Rob and and attack cops
and guess what it's actually happening
now so you're saying it's lying through
a mission he's not including the full
context of the letter when we get when
we get people like Glenn Greenwald
coming out and saying well look Ben
Laden said they were mad about us for he
was mad about foreign policy no no no no
no no BLM comes out and says police are
attacking us so we want to abolish the
police we're now 3 years past the summer
of love and what's happening they're
they just released two in New York who
mercilessly beat a cop without bail we
had a woman who was just killed and I I
think it was in Georgia I'm not sure
where it was because the guy got
released without bail everything they
said they said these cops are killing us
so we need to stop this they weren't
actually mad cops were killing them they
were mad that cops were stopping
criminals from doing extremist things
okay so I I I just don't I don't think
the comparison is perfect I get your
point on the BL stuff that but okay sure
go so you read the first line you attack
us want me to read you the first line of
what he defines
you got I'm not going to read the whole
thing on the show long but he says uh in
the first section under your supervision
consent and orders the governments of
our countries which act as your agents
attack us on a daily basis one these
governments prevent our people from
establishing Islamic Sharia using
violence and lies to do so okay two they
humiliate us three so when you ask him
what does it mean to be attacked on a
daily basis he is not saying I can't
believe that you're shooting at us he's
saying we want Sharia he goes on to say
the whole second half number two Tim Tim
what he's clarifying there is that
you're you're toppling the leadership
that they want you're basically you're
in they're asking for autonomy I
disagree with them but but if they want
autonomy they want if they want
sovereignty then they can have it so my
point is this these leftists it all
comes down to have not actually read the
letter do not actually understand what
his his goals I agree with you that they
didn't read it but doesn't change the
fact that he has some legitimate gri
well let's say they're all wrong right
and obviously any leftist who's going to
say realizing Osama Bin Laden was right
about everything is like Beyond stupid
and just it it's insane obviously forget
any of that if your conclusion from any
of that is that therefore it's okay to
slaughter innocent people then F you
you're a horrible person you're and
you're a Madman but I think the point is
what should like like not the leftist
interpretation of this but say like the
the Ron Paul interpretation of this
which I think he was completely right
about and the Papu Canon like I'm
talking about the most right-wing and
the most Libertarian not left-wingers at
all and the point that they would make
is that it's like look there's the P
Buchanan quote that I love which I think
Nails it always right is he says
terrorism is the price of Empire and if
you don't wish to pay the cost you must
abandon the Empire and I think what
you're dealing with here is that listen
these are a group of people who have a
different way of life than us and a
different belief system than us and I'm
not defending that way of life or that
belief system but when you go over there
and you impose your own brutal dictators
on them you in civilians so but I'm
saying but so that's what I think should
be gained from this
by those parts are legitimate Grievances
and my issue
is no one disagrees but well some do but
my point is here in this room we get it
US foreign policy has been a disaster
Afghanistan is the latest in a long line
of disasters I think it would be unfair
to say every single thing ever done was
a disaster but boy did the US lose a lot
of wars in the past 70 years lose L lose
lose lose but for these leftists to do
two things one claim Bin Laden was right
and actually be activist who a prop
Palestine who read it well they're lying
and they're manipulating and they're
trying to obfuscate what his actual
goals were and two the other leftists
who are claiming they read it and they
thought he was right they did not read
it
that's don't my point that bothers me is
people who are arguing that like like
Glenn greenwald's tweet is irksome that
is not Bin Laden's grievance they are
they are they are they are single facts
of things that he's using examples of of
how we stopped him from having Sharia
and let me let me read section three I
read you section one section three you
are a nation that permits the production
trading and usage of intoxicants you
permit drugs and only forbid the trade
of them even though your nation is the
largest consumer of them he says uh uh
where where's the you are a nation that
permits acts of immorality and you
consider them be pillars of personal
freedom youve Contin to sink down the
abyss from level to level etc etc he
goes on to say if I go uh into the
earlier
you allow fornication homosexuality
gambling and Usery yeah
so when he's mad about US foreign policy
that's like starting to sound like Kanye
when when when he's mad about US foreign
policy it's not for the reason the
anti-war Americans are I I don't agree
with that Tim if you've read the whole
thing as I have yes you're right he
makes a whole bunch of points that I I
disagree with but he also makes a ton of
points that are totally legit he says
you have aggressed upon my people for
decades after decades he talks about how
how Israel was foed upon the Arab world
and that they they opposed the UN
declaration that made it come to pass I
get it I mean like he like yes he has a
bunch of that I disagree with but
then he's got to he's a murderous he's a
murderous psychopath he's also break
he's also raising some grievances you
know what he's saying like I I compare
this to BLM okay the u i I don't think
the US should be going to foreign
countries and doing these things but the
argument that is from the left is
essentially let us do horrifying things
to people slave trade uh uh child
marriage all these awful things that's
what he's saying right so how dare you
stop us from do so he's wrong and and
the he's a bad guy I mean that should
bad guy that should be the conclusion of
all this but I will
say my point comes down to leftists on
Tik Tok claiming he was right when his
message is he wants Sharia so okay so
the leftists are wrong for claiming that
he's wrong for wanting Sharia law but I
just think look so let's again those
people are wrong but let's just talk
about what's right for a minute and I'll
say this this this is a point that I
tried to make uh in in the debate I did
last night with Laura lumer for Zero
Hedge but she was basically just like
condemning Islam the whole time and
talking about and I was trying to just
just have this moment of being like well
look let's just try to be really fair
here okay so let's try to think this
through and I'm not obviously Bin
Laden's a bad guy but think about what
we did after 9/11 how crazy we went as a
country like in terms of how what we
would support what our government did
what the response to it was that we look
back at this now and we go wait so we
got essentially missil bombed with two
planes and and World Trade Center and we
we created the Department of Homeland
Security and the Patriot Act and the TSA
and the war in Afghanistan and the war
in Iraq which we almost all universally
look back on and go whoa that was wrong
John McCain in his Memoir wrote that the
war in Iraq was a mistake so almost
everybody like acknowledges like we went
a little bit crazy after 911 and did a
whole bunch of bad things a lot of
innocent people died over that now try
to imagine and I want you to really try
to imagine this that
1,911 happened to us and what that would
look like how crazy we would go that's
the reality in the Muslim world now I'm
not saying this justifies any of this
and if your takeaway of this is that
Osama Bin Laden is a good guy you might
be an idiot 16-year-old leftist but I'm
just saying that before we sit here and
condemn them for how a they and I think
this is the point that Glenn Greenwald
is trying to get at here is that it's
like look when what he's talking about
in this letter is describing a, 911s and
if you actually do the numbers in terms
of dead it's probably more than that but
whatever just imagining that and so if
we're going to sit here and our reaction
to that is going to be like but you're a
radical islamist and all of this is
crazy that you want Sharia law okay fine
and fine but seeing as what our reaction
was just after one 911 I don't know that
after you know after a th 911s Sheamus
gets in control what do you think he's
going to going to be some radical
Christianity me tell his b based
what should these leftists do to remedy
what they've done and you know what the
answer is become straight convert to
islt to Islam explicitly says as a
second question what are we calling you
to do calling you to Islam the religion
of unification of God Bin Laden attacked
us for two reasons he says because you
opposed you you've obstructed our our
the life that we want the rules that we
want he says specifically your attacks
on us include fornication gambling Usery
Etc and what do we want you to do now
join
Islam
usy but not alcohol that's what I'm
saying all right okay we might meet in
the middle there uh but do you think let
me ask you this Tim do you think and I
mean this is a real human terms like
trying to put yourself in in the
position of of these people do you think
Osama Bin Laden was able to recruit
people to be willing to Suicide bomb
themselves to death because like do you
think a pretty major factor of that was
that maybe they had seen someone who
they loved start the first J the the
first Jihad I I I don't know well I I I
I kind of think if you have I don't know
the first Jihad which is what was it
went on for a thousand plus years and
they went from uh the Middle East all
throughout Europe up into Spain I don't
I don't know was that caused by a th
911s was it like oh I
think but I think I think going that far
back in history kind ofs like I have I
have to make this point because in the
in the letter itself he says 3,000 of
your people die and all hell breaks
loose 1.5 million of our people die and
you won't even you won't even blink an
eye the point that he's making uh
setting aside all of the islamist
all of the all of the leftist
argumentation is that we don't treat
them as if they're real people we treat
them as if they're lesser and that's
true well and and and until until we're
willing to accept that reality and
actually like look in the mirror if I
was born in Gaza in 2006
I would be of fighting age today and I
would have never had any sovereignty
whatsoever I'm ruled by Hamas I'm ruled
by the IDF if I go too close to the
Border I get shot I would be a complete
lunatic anytime you bring this up people
say oh you're trying to you're trying to
justify terrorism you're trying to you
know make it sound as if Hamas is the
good guys I'm not doing that what I'm
doing is I'm putting myself in the shoes
of people that have been legitimately
oppressed and I'm not talking about the
critical oppression I'm talking about
real effing oppression where your whole
life has been let me ask you a question
why were the Marines formed the and and
what did what what did the sultan say to
Thomas Jefferson which require resulted
in him saying you know what fine then
we're forming the Marines but the the
well the Pirates were brib or uh
demanding uh R when when the American
ships were being attacked by the North
African barbery States Jefferson and
Adams many other uh us uh agents were
like yo we got no problem with you guys
why are you consistently attacking our
ships and you know what the response was
our religion says we're allowed to do it
yeah yeah okay so he said if that's what
you're going to do I am going to raise a
navy and I will wipe you out and it was
probably a big mistake by the way the
English
Empire I mean think about the
implications of first off he didn't get
a declaration of war from Congress he
just went about it with having Thomas
Mark Mark and reprisal that was that was
the the point no no no they got kind of
it wasn't even Mark in reprisal it was
kind of like almost an authorization of
mil Force typee deal by the way the
French and the British had forever just
been paying those pirates off paying the
ransom and I think he ended up spending
a lot more money on than if he had just
paid them off so people died and he
wasted a lot of money I'm not saying
it's the right thing to do the Pirates
were the aggressors in that but here's
my issue with this my issue with when we
go back to like okay but look in the
year uh
1801 a radical Muslim did this or that
here's kind of the problem that look
there uh do you guys familiar with the
uh King crane commission no okay so the
king crane commission was uh after World
War I uh at the end of World War I I
think it started at the Paris peace
conference and they were trying to get
the British and the French on board but
they kind of pulled out of it so the
Americans just did it without him but
they sent a commission into uh the
Muslim world because the Ottoman Empire
had collapsed and now there were all
these territories that used to be ruled
by the Ottoman Empire and they were kind
of going on like a fact-f finding
Mission like they went there to just
kind of like survey and interview a lot
of people and figure out what we're
going to do with this part of the world
and there's a few really interesting
things that they found number one uh
Syria overwhelmingly voted and Syria
back then was much bigger than Syria
today but so it's like the land Syria is
and then I think a bigger area than that
overwhelmingly they said who would you
like to to rule you under a League of
Nations mandate and overwhelmingly Syria
voted for the United States of America
so it this narrative that they hate us
because we're fre is really not very
true in fact when we were viewed as the
ones who weren't the imperialist force
remember this is World War I okay they
they were like America the city on the
hill that's all about freedom and
doesn't intervene in our part of the
world we love those guys like they had
nothing but a positive feeling about
those guys and likewise early on if you
read the early Zionist writers they were
not like they didn't consider the Arabs
to be an enemy so my my point is just
that actually a lot of I'm not saying
every the problem with when you go back
to say like the 7th Century or you go
back hundreds and hundreds of years and
go look they were being barbaric then
the truth is that everyone was being
barbaric then if we if we look at more
recent and more relevant history you
realize that actually there a lot of
this the syrians had no problem with
America they hated the British and the
French why is that social media
algorithms are resulting in people
sharing things they don't understand and
I don't I agree with you and what I am
bothered by is seeing people I can use
the specific example of Glen Greenwald
instead of pointing out what's going on
misrepresenting the summation of what
Bin Laden wrote for the justification of
their ideology I don't think he's
misrepresenting it I think he literally
is well no I think he's trying to point
out what he views as the most important
aspect of that and I think maybe you're
pointing out what you view as the most
important aspect of that I think I'll
tell you what I'm I'm pointing out the
letter has two questions the first one
is 50/50 between the prevention of
sharia law and allowing of homosexuality
along with foreign policy from the
United States and the second part is
that the US is not Islamic if you're
going to claim his three grievances are
us specific US foreign policy actions
you are misrepresenting what been he
also says that he was but he did mention
all of those specific grievances that
Glenn Greenwald laid out so my guess
would be and maybe this is a more
charitable interpretation but I think
that what Glenn Greenwald is saying is
essentially that like kind of my
position on this that well obviously
it's a given that Osama Bin Laden's a
bad guy and an islamist like no one's I
mean I guess some crazy 16-year-olds are
but no normal person is really
questioning that that's not the point at
G and now let me clarify for you again
if Bin Laden says I attacked you because
of these things and Glenn says actually
it was these things that's
misrepresentation but he does fa he does
say those things Bin Laden says there
are two main
points okay the first being the attacks
on us which includes physical and
ideological okay and the second half of
is you must become Muslim and then and
then Glen goes actually it was only
about US foreign policy he he three
points and he names three specific for
I'll tell you what bothers me what
bothers me is when activists with policy
ends lie to gain power it's not it's not
a lie as much as you're saying he left
out part of it he mentioned three things
explicitly States in his tweet that his
his three main grievances are so he
claims those are the main Grievances and
they're not there's two main grievances
one is the attack on them and their
ideology both physical and ideological
and the second is that we must convert
to Islam so when people say they hate us
for our freedoms I think it's stupid and
oversimplified you could say well look
and you're saying this is stupid and
over over we when we engage in Foreign
Wars which destroy the way of life of
people who don't want to live the way we
do we're making enemies and what they
want is for us to convert to their way
of life if if if the United States
foreign policy acted in ways that
resulted in the benefit of Islam Bin
Laden would have been happy and he would
have wrote that see here's the issue
though possibly up until up until there
was decades of interference into the
Middle East they weren't actually trying
to get us to convert it like yes his
letter this aspect of his letter
obviously I reject it and I'm not going
to become a Muslim to acques to Osama
bin Lan's demands good call yeah well
you you'll be relieved to know he's dead
yes well thank goodness uh but but all
I'm taking away from this letter is is
what aligns with with reality and what
does align with reality is that we have
bombed his people four decades and he
does categorize that he says that the
sanctioned regime in Iraq you guys don't
care about this he says we have tried to
be civil we have tried to rationalize I
pointed that out I agree the point is
but that matters that's important to
talk broken into two sections you have
physically and ideologically attacked us
and you won't convert let me read
another section for you this is section
2A of his second half of this letter we
call you to be people of manners
principles honor and Purity to reject
the immoral acts of fornication
homosexuality intoxicant gambling and
trading with interest to say his main
grievances are specifically US foreign
policy is wrong is he mad about us also
there were many other speeches and many
other letters that he where he he
mentioned these grievances over and over
so you're right again he's a radical
islamist like yeah like I don't know why
why are
people I'm I'm I'm going to it plainly I
am sick of ideologues manipulating for
their personal ideological ends but
you're making it sound as if it's not
actually listed it he does no I agree it
is listed there's two sections the
ideological and physical attacks as well
as we not converting to Islam ISL those
are the two main what I'm taking from it
is what do I have control over I'm not
going to become a radical islamist I'm
not going to adapt Sharia law what I can
do is get my effing State Department to
stop here just explain kind of why I I
disagree with you the question is simply
this would AMA Bin Laden is are you
arguing that he only attacked us because
of US foreign policy let me say I think
he would not have I don't think he would
have had the capacity to attack us if
not for the radicalization that
psychopath our sanction he was a
psychopath I think the reason he was
able to recruit enough people who were
willing to to commit suicide and
attacking us was probably blowback but
let me say this this I think is
essentially my disagreement with you and
like you use the kind of black lives
matter Michael Brown analogy I'd look at
it kind of like if you were let's say
you were trapping someone in your
basement and torturing them every single
day and they are they went crazy and
completely lost their mind and wrote
some Manifesto and half of the manifesto
was like just the rantings of a Madman
and half of it was like and you came
down here and you beat me with a wire
every single day and that's why I'm
going to try to kill you and then that
guy came and killed you I'd go well yeah
I mean look at the manifesto he came and
killed you because you were torturing
him every day whereas someone else could
look at that and go no these are the r
things of a mad
man the analogy is one for one no it's
not perfect it's not a Perfect Analogy
but the Mike Brown analogy isn't a
Perfect Analogy either I'm just saying
that is iown my point with Mike Brown is
specifically for the leftists who are
adopting this and claiming he's right
when well they're stupid and then when
when people like Glenn come out and say
well Bin Laden was mad about war this
fuels the indoctrination of moronic
Millennials and you keep saying 16year
olds but dude these are millennials who
are in their 30s no I know they're still
16 but I get your boy they're very old
and they're running for office and
they're in office and they're and
they're chanting these things in the
streets they're in New York celebrating
MOS I get your point on that I'm just
saying that also I mean Glenn Greenwald
has like been serving them a heavy dose
of reality through all of this I'm going
where I think he need be criti fair
enough fair enough but I'm also saying
that I don't technically think he said
anything wrong if you want to say he
omitted the fact that Osama Bin Laden is
also a radical islamist I would just be
charitable and say like I think that's a
given for same people it's not a given
for these people that you're pulling up
so fair enough anyone who read Glenn
greenwald's tweet would have a would
have a an incorrect interpretation of
the of the summation of the letter I
think I think if they only heard your
interpretation they'd have an incorrect
summation too I I gave you the two full
points and and and gave you the there's
a lot that's included in there the the
sanction regime you didn't mentioned
that was 1.5 million he says you killed
we killed 3,000 of yours all of a sudden
you care the whole reason
the physical attacks on their
countries because he's saying he's
saying I have tried to have civil
conversation you all don't listen to us
you only respond to aggression we're
going to give you aggression I'm not
justifying any of this and there is a
point in section one if I'm not mistaken
because I I didn't get a chance to read
this today when we found it because it's
been scrubbed from the Internet it's
been years since I've read this and so
I'm going off M but I did think in
section one he did list out those three
grievances right like I understand there
were the two sections but I think he did
list out the three grievances of like
military bases in Saudi
Arab the first gance is the first
Palestine is is the first griev is
Palestine so for Glenn to say it's Iraq
and it's is Israel and then Saudi land
when actually the first point was be
Israel then Iraq then Saudi so it's it's
Israel it is Israel it is Israel it is
Israel okay then it's Somalia uh number
five is Somalia
then it's uh uh the next section goes on
to be like you guys use violence to
prevent Sharia everywhere but he doesn't
talk about a global caliphate he's not
talking no I know but but the point
you're bringing up with these specific
things I'm not there yet I'm in section
uh seven not there yet eight not there
yet nine Palestine still uh 10 uh still
not there still we want Sharia law and
you're blocking Sharia the next one is
uh okay you're stealing our oil and it's
the biggest theft in mankind okay still
not those specific military things but
yes generally foreign policy here we go
finally I think we're at Point 13 you
occupy our countries with military bases
and allow Jews to you're skipping over
number one after like paragraph two
where he says because you attacked us
and continue to attack us and then he
says a you attacked us in Palestine and
then he start this how many times do I
got to say the first section is that we
attack them well I know but you're
saying say that you're saying he doesn't
do it until the very end that's not true
he does do it in the very end that Glenn
Greenwald made have not even come up
after the 15 you're saying you're saying
that uh the the Iraq blockade come up
until much later I'm saying that for
Glenn to make these points that these
are the main grievances is Glenn
choosing subjects that benefit his
ideology and it's manipulative and I I
am sick of ideologues who do this I
don't care if you're the Left Right
libertarian up down whatever I don't
care if you're Christian Muslim whatever
if you're going to lie to me to steal
power I'm going to call you out for it
well I don't think Glenn Greenwald is
trying to steal any power I he's trying
to impose his ideologically ideological
values by obusca what's actually being
said he has his own bias when he reads
this he takes away certain you you know
notes that he thinks that that's the
yeah can we sayen screw Glenn Greenwald
and let's talk about the substance of
this letter for a little bit point is
just using him as a singular example the
left is arguing that Bin Laden is right
because the first 15 paragraphs are
almost entirely about Palestine and and
the context is Israel and Palestine are
currently in a the hottest conflict
we've seen in our lifetimes and so they
are deciding to claim all of his stuff
about Sharia and Islam is also cor well
look I mean look again I think you can
say this and I know there's a tendency
for people to kind of caricature what
characterize what you say but uh why is
it that this is there's fertile ground
for even this type of craziness to take
off right now and it is because well
look there's this war in Gaza going on
right now which is pretty horrific and a
lot of like innocent people are dying in
that war and so even when you have this
letter that's talking all about how
those people over there hate you in
large part because of what your
government has propped up Israel to be
able to do in Gaza this is probably at
least partially why there's fertile
ground for this narrative to catch fire
right now not that doesn't mean it's
completely right no it's it's actually
not right but the here's the problem is
that we lied to the American people not
we but the government did they
didn't tell us the truth about why they
were actually upset with us so now you
have all of these kids that are growing
up going like they hate us because we're
free and then they realize oh it's
actually not just that it's actually not
cuz it's not true and it hasn't been
true from the beginning so so because
they were deceived now they go to tick
tock to learn history lessons and then
they get misled and we're all upset
about it well how't we just start by
telling the truth my point is social
media is indoctrinating young people the
Millennials and lower into psychotic
beliefs this kid I pointed up did not
just say we were lied to he says Bin
Laden was right okay now that's
stupid but here's the really sad thing
Tim even though you're right and that is
insane they're getting better history
than George W bush taught him so as as
crazy as all of this is at least now
they're hearing the other side of the
story they're still reaching a very dumb
conclusion if their conclusion is Osama
Bin Laden was right they did not read
the letter okay I I don't know there's
no way of knowing that for sure there's
no there's no reasonable way to say that
a leftist agrees with the statement that
we must ban homosexuality I agree I
agree with you here's why I I think
you're you're wrong in a sense because
the leftists will be
so hypocritical that almost every
situation they look at they have to look
at it through who is the oppressor
versus who is the oppressed and whoever
is the more white European looking ones
is always the mor and if those two
things completely contradict each other
it doesn't
matter in general if a Muslim is being
oppressed then they'll be like okay
we're on the side of the Muslim and then
if they feel like a gay person's being
oppressed they're on the side of the gay
person and the fact that that Muslim and
that gay person would not get along very
well does not like register and I agree
with you but it's more mostly about
ignorance like when they have queers for
Palestine and they made the pride
Palestine flag there's a big difference
between not knowing anything and just
waving a flag and reading a direct
statement that says abandon and ban
Osama Bin Laden woke up and was like
geez it's 8:30 a.m. well Osama Bin Laden
was right that doesn't mean that he's
right about everything he said probably
some things in here are correct it's
specifically about why they were
attacking he seems pretty honest
palestin stuff but then we got to be
clear he didn't say that they're
fighting us because we won't adopt
Sharia part of it is you won't let us
practice our Sharia in our countries of
choice so we will fight then the part of
the second part what are we calling on
you to do now is like adopt Sharia
they're pissed they're beyond the pale
at that point yes because he says you
guys have aggressed so so consistently
and you don't listen to reason you don't
listen to rational discussion you don't
want to have any negotiations you want
to be you don't want to be civil at all
think about this we we phrase these
radical jihadis as the most unil bar
barbaric people on the planet they look
at us the Americans and they say y'all
aren't civil think about how crazy that
is the head choppers in Syria think that
the American Empire isn't civil people
need to internalize this actually think
about what they're saying there that's
profound that's profound that they think
that we are The Barbarians on Earth take
like take it in for a second for real
well you know this is something that I
kind of like came across in in the
debate I was doing last night and
there's part of this uh thing where PE
look we are
unquestionably say the United States of
America and and Israel uh compared to
the Muslim World in which we've fought a
lot of Wars over the last couple decades
we are undeniably much more advanced
much more sophisticated uh much more
systematized and they are much more
primitive than us and so it's very easy
for people to go like you know what
people who are on say like the
pro-israeli side of the the argument if
you go well look I mean Hamas killed all
these people I think that's really wrong
what happened on October 7th but then
look Israel's killing all these innocent
people in response and I think that's
wrong it's very easy for them to be like
no no no no no that was barbarians
targeting civilians and this is
Collateral Damage Done by military
strikes and it's very easy in the
Western World to feel this difference
that like well that no but that's just
different you know what I mean this is
kind of like look this is bad
policy or even good policy that happens
to have these negative you know uh um
results but if those are your kids and
your sisters and your mothers and your
wives who are dying as a result of that
policy it is very easy to say that is
every bit as barbaric that is every bit
as evil as whatever you know what I mean
like could be done in return well it's
even more brutal cuz you're coming from
a very poor place like the people in
Gaza are so destitute you have a full
sanction regime all they've dealt with
is bombardment year after year sniper
fire these people have been radicalized
and we and we refuse to just look in the
damn mirror and say why why is this
happening can we do anything to actually
intervene on behalf of these people as
opposed to just going look at what Hamas
did let's flatten everybody let's let's
continue the cycle of death and
destruction all I'm calling upon people
to do is to actually reflect on what got
us here that doesn't justify anything it
doesn't say that Hamas are the good
people it says can we stop this cycle of
violence can we and and for a lot of
people the answer is no we can't I
reject that please religious man back me
up here I can't speak and this is what I
well I can't it's been hard to get a
word gen edwi but I I can't speak to the
the specific history of the Israel
Palestine conflict CU I don't know much
about it but what I will say is you can
acknowledge that Islam has a unique
problem of violence while also looking
at the United States seeing our own
history recognizing that for example in
2001 when New York was attacked we felt
that was an attack on our whole country
and rightly so I have friends born and
raised in Georgia who fought up who
enlisted to fight in a war in the Middle
East because people who they'd never met
in their entire lives and probably never
would were killed in a different state
same and so it's reasonable to say that
even if I don't agree
with their cause for them as people to
have their neighbors or family members
killed in these conflicts and then have
that result in them wanting to take up
arms against the West well it's not
something I'm saying I uh agree with
Osama Bin Laden it is to say that that's
predictable yes exactly predict this is
what look look all of the wisest people
who predicted everything that's gone
wrong over the last 30 years in America
I mean like all of the best people like
the Pat Buchanan and the Ron Pauls and
like all of the guys who stood up and
were right about all of this stuff they
always said like again to mention that P
Buchanan quote that terrorism is the
price of Empire and if you want and this
is all of it this isn't an Islamic like
problem look at the the Irish when the
British were dominating them he
literally pointed at my alcohol by the
way when he's like look at the IR this
guy over look at these look at these
sloppy drugs okay but right okay this is
true all around the world terrorism is
is almost always the tool of the
dominated like this is what this is what
they have left in their Arsenal and I'm
not saying that they might have some
goofy beliefs that also go along with
that because when people get desperate
they tend to cling to whoever the most
radical person around trying to recruit
them is let's clarify the George bushan
terrorism
was insurgents and militants have
attacked our military that's terrorism
they call it a terror attack when a bomb
is planted in a military hold on if our
military is being attacked by Foreign
fighters in a foreign country that we
invaded that's not terrorism right
they're calling it that because they
want to win a political Point terrorism
is why did Hamas Target the music
festival they that that's terrorism
targeting civilians intentionally for
the purpose of gaining leverage over
your enemy terrorizing the people in the
country to win political power they they
they want to inct they want to inflict
as much damage as possible on civilians
because they know that the action will
be catastrophic and because of that the
rest of the Arab world and the Muslim
world may rally to the defense that is
the ex that is exactly what terrorism is
is designed to do Blumenthal said max
blumthal said that Hamas targeted Music
Festival as a target of opportunity
knowing they could use civilians as
leverage against the Israeli government
and uh I think the general assessment is
Hamas wanted to disrupt the Abraham
Accords and they wanted to force like
the United States what did they do but
Biden promises $100 million to the strip
and the West Bank of which a lot of that
will flow into yeah but look I mean
again and this is uh just to be clear
here if I if you ever say put yourself
in their shoes this is not saying
therefore they're right about everything
I'm just saying to understand the
situation what were the Abraham Accords
really okay for years okay even under uh
when I was a kid under Yak Rabin uh who
was the Prime Minister of Israel the and
and from way before then the entire
framing of the conflict between Israel
and the Palestinians was basically that
look there is this resentment within the
Arab world that Israel illegitimately
got this land and kicked all of these
Muslims off of this land to create their
country and then continued not only did
they take what the UN partition uh
recommendation recommended by force but
then they took way more than that and
then way more than that by War and this
isn't right and all these Arabs are
should be allowed to return that's their
perspective okay and forever and all the
way up to Yak Rabin in the 9s the idea
was that look we have to either make
peace or kind of pretend to make peace
or at least act as if we're offering a
two-state solution here before we can
ever make peace with the broader Arab
world the Netanyahu strategy was to go
screw that y we're never making peace
with these Palestinians you'll never get
your state we're going to support Hamas
just so you don't get your state and
what we're going to do is try to buy off
with US taxpayer dollars the rest of the
Arab world to abandon your cause and
recognize us and normalize relationships
with us even though we will never give
you your state wait wait is that bad
well I'm not saying forget even the mor
yes I do think it's bad but forget even
the moral judgment for a second I'm
saying put yourself in the shoes of the
Palestinians this deal is now to buy off
your last Lifeline which would be these
surrounding Arab countries and that you
will never get you you there's no more
hope you will be dominated forever so of
course they would want to break up those
what do people without hope do radical
things and and my point is just the
distinction between the George bushan
description of terrorism when they say
oh some Iraqis just blew up a truck
they're terrorists it's like well dude
you're you're an invading military force
in a country that so you're saying
they're defending themselves versus
people who are aggressing against defend
I'm saying military action is different
from people cians targeting civilians
explicitly for for for gain I completely
agree with that but I'm not even saying
you don't have to Define them the way
I'm defining I'm saying there's a
distinction between two and typically in
American foreign policy they say oh what
when when people refer to the George
Bush era definition of terrorism when
they when they were saying things like
you'll get terrorism well they were
talking in the news about Iraqis or
afghanis bombing US military targets and
then the media would call them that a
terrorist attack because it scared
people in the same way 911 did sure no
but when I was referring to Pap
Buchanan's quote he was talking about
911 he was talking about the African
Embassy bomb so like so I get your point
look if you're fighting off an invading
Army is a very different thing than
attacking people in a country that's
dominating your country what I what I
what I I guess the broader point is 911
was a terrorist attack they attacked
civilian targets they killed thousands
of civilians and then that freaked
Americans out to a great degree y the us
then invades for some reason Iraq
whatever and when the Iraqis resist the
reason they call it terrorism is to
invoke the same sense of dread and fear
in Americans that they felt from 911
even though it's a
military absurdly unfair to the Iraqis
who had every right to defend themselves
from the American Empire that was
attacking them for no reason at all in
hindsight zero reason there's a reason
please yeah we set up military bases in
Iraq and Afghanistan surrounding Iran
because we also want to attack Iran well
that's right a lot of reasons but look I
re good I think like like and and this
is what I try to say with this when you
first start if if you're trying to first
start understanding the whole thing and
then because you got to understand it
before you can really know what the
correct policy is but if you understand
cuz really like I remember um there
there was I was on a I used to I was a
contributor on Essie cup show uh which
she had a show on uh on on CNN back in
uh this was like in 2017 or something
like that and there was like this I'm
such an OG Dave Smith fan I watched
every single episode well you're one of
the 17 people who watched that
show didn't go great but it was good
money it was a good time and I you know
it was it was fun for me at the time um
but there was this ISIS attack in New
York City and a very on the scale of
terrorism a very minor one I mean it it
was I I don't remember trash yeah it was
a truck crash and he jumped out he he
hit someone with the van then jumped out
and shot off a gun and he said he was
Isis but like even that it wasn't even
like really connected it was like a
crazy
here who to be Muslim who to say I'm
with Isis and um so we're going around
this panel and I was just making the
argument about how you know like you
know we always say we have to attack him
over there so we don't have to fight him
over here but the more we fight him over
there the more we're fighting him over
here and how there's kind of this cycle
of blowback and then there was a this
this Democratic strategist who was next
to me I went off on a rant of of the way
I tend to do and then he just goes to me
and he goes
yeah but I don't I'm sorry but so you're
just saying we have to do nothing you're
saying the response to this is we have
to do nothing I think we have to do
something and that was all he said and
this was like a professional Democratic
strategist and that was his takeaway it
was like you like it it literally I I
felt like a caveman was next to me like
you go you say nothing I say something
and and I went oh okay you should said
getting rid of our bases isn't nothing
right well right but well yeah I but I
kind of looked at and I was like well
look but do you see how you're feeling
right now we got to do something and
what do you mean by something you mean
kill some people like it's like our
people got killed what are you saying we
don't go kill some of their people and
don't we totally understand right
everyone totally understands where after
October 7th what's the Israeli
response flatten Gaza right what are the
calls from all the politicians are you
out of your mind are these innocent and
by the way I'm saying I understand that
response I understand look dude when you
look at those pictures of of babies who
died on October 7th I I look at those
pictures I see my kids faces in those
kids faces it's horrific I think to
myself how would I feel if those were my
kids and I'll tell you I'd feel exactly
that way I feel exactly that way
somebody better die over this and I
don't even really care if some innocent
people get killed so whoever did this
better die over this but then look at
the babies of the Dead Palestinians and
just understand if for nothing else
other than just for strategic
empathy understand it so you know what's
going on here that they also feel that
way about their kids and I'll to be
honest I also see my kids faces in those
dead Palestinian kids faces and it's
like okay so once you understand that
you recognize that you're like this
whole cycle is only going to continue
until we recognize that there's actually
sure they might be islamists and we're
more secular or something like that but
the Thunder FAL thing that's going
obviously certain excl but listen the
fundamental thing that's going on here
is something that unites us more than
divides us that we're both responding to
the fact that our people got killed and
now we got to go kill your people and we
want to protect our children that that's
a very human instinct regardless of our
cultural differences I know we got to go
to super chats but before we do that I
just want to say real quick
look I'm a finance guy all of the
inflationary pressures that we're
dealing with right now now are a product
of our Empire the the dollar Reserve
currency status whether you care about
the Palestinians or the Israelis it's
really Irrelevant for your own family
sake for the the the sake of everyone
you know and love when it comes to your
capacity to save and invest and retire
buy things everything is predicated off
of whether or not the American
government and the American people are
willing to be adults about the situation
that we sit we stand in today and we say
we can't continue down this path it's
totally self-destructive it's actually
suicide of what we're doing to ourselves
so we have to take a non-interventionist
position moving forward not just for the
sake of the world but also for ourselves
and I'll can I just say one last thing
before we go to super chats and I'll try
to keep this as brief as possible but I
know Tim that like even in some areas
where we may like have some slight
disagreements on this because I I listen
to the show regularly and I know that
you are completely me and you totally
agree on what the American policy on
this should be which is that you're like
this is not our fight we should not be
involved on this like yes yes that
we why the why on Earth are we when
we're 30 plus trillion dollars in debt
trying to get involved in every single
fight and fund every every other country
and all of this but I will just say this
because I mentioned the king crane
commission before uh so the king crane
commission one last thing that was
really interesting about their findings
because they go have you read this Clint
really good you should check this out
going fascinating so they go after World
War I so the balour declaration has
already been made where the British
basically said uh we it pleases the king
that the Jews have a homeland in
Palestine as long as they don't violate
the the rights of the non-jewish
population there and one of the things
that the king crane commission came back
after interviewing and surveying
thousands of people in Palestine is they
came back and they gave this
recommendation to woodr Wilson who was
the president at the time and they were
like listen Mr President let me just
tell you about this Bal for declaration
it is unworkable because there is no way
that the Zionist project can go
forward while being in consistent with
the rights of the non-jewish people in
the land and they said it will take an
army they they uh a military force they
said of at least 50,000 people to force
this on the Arabs and they said just no
Mr President woodro Wilson that you're
not only if you're supporting the
Zionist project you're not only
committing yourself but you're
committing America to supporting force
against the Arab population to create
and make
maintain a Jewish Jewish State here so
basically what they were saying now wood
Wilson ended up having a stroke and
being incapacitated best thing he ever
did in his administration but then he
never got this uh this message but I'm
just saying when they said to create and
maintain they basically said if you're
going to support Israel what is now
Israel you're committing in perpetuity
oh yeah to commit Force against this
part of the world and I think that's
something that we have to recognize it
might be worth it but understand that
there is a cost that comes along with
that we're going to go to super chats so
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
go to
timcast.net
[Laughter]
check out tomorrow's culture War episode
on tenant media where we're going to
have Scott Horton and Will Chamberlain
debating is
but we'll read your super chats now
Clint Torres says how do people Tim I'll
be leaving the country tonight for a few
days so there will be ample opportunity
for others to pretend to be the fastest
Ah that's right Clint is always the
first Super Chat thinking about you last
night Clint yeah I've been I've been
doing that uh from my phone at home I am
actually Clint taus so that's uhw that's
you huh no I'm just kidding I just
thought it'd be funny if it were all
right volon says the Alex Jones video
game is hilarious yeah you guys see this
no I haven't I saw that there was some
Hub up about it as the kid say but I
haven't seen the
game what do we have here we'll grab
some more Super chats all right scroll
down uh Alpha Turkey saying the Osama
thing with jenzi is wild wild is
certainly one way to say it yeah all
right Curtis C says white wheelchair
Santa is $140 more than black wheelchair
Santa That's patriarchy really H Tian
the Husky says Lauren has a lot of
passion but she is unable to listen and
understand other points of view 30 going
13 seems like Lauren Laura lummer I I
think they mean Laura cuz you mentioned
oh Laura lumer oh yeah yeah they're
talking about when I argued with you and
Lauren Southern on culture War yeah that
was my first thought I don't think they
were talking about Lauren Southern they
were creator of INF right austo MIM says
it's my birthday and I can't think of a
better birthday gift than having Dave
Smith on IRL the only thing I ask for is
Dave's Trump impression I don't really
do a very good Trump impression nobody
does give me Trump getting us out of the
Middle Eastern Wars
oh Tim does the best Trump Yeah Tim
Dylan uh no not Tim Dylan uh
Shane Shane does the best Shane
Shane I people I mean I guess if that's
what people it's great I don't think so
maybe we'll do it in the in the members
only and we'll see if I can I kind of
feel like I can do Impressions if no one
tells me to do an impression you know I
mean I didn't mean top you I'm just
saying people are like so people love my
Pelosi impersonation because my my
Pelosi impersonation is just intended to
make her sound as disgusting as possible
TR it's so disgusting and it's not
really meant to impersonate hery dud we
played poker
last feel the same thing that I feel
when she speaks and that's what
impression we played poker the last time
I was here and these two were just doing
Trump Impressions back and
forth by the way happy birthday to the
guy who
said Mr M himself Sheamus and I were
doing this thing where it was Trump and
mini Trump and then I would do a trump
imp impersonation and then he would do a
higher pitch version of it but then I
guess he found out someone actually
already did z h already did a bit like
that like that's unfortunate unfortunate
happy 70 happy 7th birthday to my dad
Charlie I didn't get to see you last
week I love
you I am the voice of Dr Anthony fouchy
on the recur recurring cast member on
freedom what happened was like Trump
trump was like the reasonable one and
then mini Trump was like the far more
offensive like awful one who just saying
all the Terrible Things the media wants
you to think Trump would say so CH be
like no we don't hate all like yes we do
we hate all it it was a lot of fun and
then and then eventually Trump has I
forgot
about tiny Trump like takes over he's
like we're getting rid of the big Donald
no more we don't need him all right
Jesus crisp says I plan on hanging
spoons with Care on my chimney this
Christmas if I'm really good and
Catholic this year maybe Sheamus will
make a visit and yes there will be a PO
Irish whiskey at oh uh I caught the cat
yesterday nice job and we named it
Sheamus they said they're going to name
the cat Sheamus dude you want funny
story my friends I went over to their
their house once and they had this like
little disabled goat and they're like
yeah we named him Sheamus and they were
like convincing me they named his sh
turns out it was totally not his name
his name was gious but like for a while
I was like I was like honored they
thought that that was going to make me
feel bad I was like that's a great name
for him I got to read this one George M
says W WTF is going on leftwing Civil
War right-wing Civil War Sheamus on
timcast no elections boys can be girls
kids praising terrorists and all I
really want to know is what does she
bring to the table
thank you if you guys want to understand
that reference go over to youtube.com/
Freedom Tunes check out our newest
Cartoon I think you'll enjoy it so now
I'm going to get to the point part of
the show where I only read the super
chats that agreed with me so sorry I
like let's go no but uh there is one and
uh we'll see there there's certainly a
lot that are calling me stupid our good
friend real Hydro is just calling me the
lowest IQ guy in the room so respect uh
we appreciate the money I'm not your
buddy guy says Tim is more right thumbs
up uh than uh Tim is more right than you
think badly then real Hydro says Tim is
an idiot and low IQ so we'll definitely
make sure we get some of those in and uh
let me try and find a good one uh let's
see let's see who sends someone money to
say that so it's such a weird I'm sorry
I mean like that's the lowest IQ thing
I've ever heard in my life I don't think
you're smart here's my
money I mean like real real Hydro is a a
regular in on the I love you real Hydro
hey send more money to Tim to tell him
how Dum he is pleas
oh but but he he he probably gives like
a hundred bucks a day to insult mew I'm
just like all right weird sub lock Hydro
I need your money I'll tell you though
there's a weird relationship with the
whole internet and everything it's
something the mix between like anonymity
and internet shows where I know people
who literally like do the same thing
like insult me on Twitter every day but
then they'll be like this thing like
they'll be like ah Dave's such an idiot
at 1 minute at 1 hour 13 minutes on his
last episode he said this which is
totally wrong and you're like dude
you're a fan you're an hour and 13
minutes into this like what is this
relationship where you consume all of my
content and then try to like hurl
insults at me the next day it's like
imagine like when we were a kid if we
could just be like H Larry David that
last episode of Seinfeld sucked and I'm
just I mean here's 20 bucks but like I
really think like like you should have
tied I buy the DD box set but you're a
real bum though so bizarre the whole
realiz it's a par antisocial
relationship they're trying to go be
parasocial they try toite you to respond
because they want to hear you respond to
them it gives people like I do exist I
am something but I found if you respond
to the negativity then they're like
that's what gets his attention they'll
do more of that that's a good you know
what Ryan long said to me this is a
hilar Ryan long you're talking after the
show at one point he's like I'm pretty
sure after two years no one has fans
anymore they all just hate you and talk
crap about you in your comment section I
was like that's the funniest thing I've
ever ever heard something that so uh
here we relate Michael oerton says
watching Dave calmly speak while Tim is
shouting makes me even more disappointed
that he couldn't run for president yeah
all right to be fair I don't think Tim
was shouting was he I'm GNA read that
i'mna also disappointed have you found
peace with your decision not to run yeah
you know I mean it's a it was a big it
was a big decision and there's
definitely uh it was a tough one you
know there's like a lot of decisions
like we all have in our careers you know
you kind of got to make decisions of
like okay I'm going to do this or I'm
going to do this moving forward and I've
always been pretty good about um you
know like okay I'm not going to live in
the past I made this
decision this one was hard I was very
seriously considering it for quite a
while and then just when it was time to
like be like okay I got to officially
make the decision there was just a lot
of family stuff going on that I was just
like I don't think this is the right
thing and um before I'm anything else
I'm a husband and a father and so that
was kind of like what I the side I aired
on but look man I'm I feel bad in the
sense that I disappoint I know there
were a lot of people who wanted me to
but I'm I'm nothing but blessed and
fortunate I have an amazing family I
have an amazing career I get to do
everything I love to do so I I love
where I am um and also I I still do
think that like I still do really think
the libertarian part is going to do
incredible things I think the mises
caucus has been an incredibly successful
movement I'm supporting Michael
rectenwald uh for president I think he's
a great candidate by far the best
candidate uh running and I think he's
going to be the libertarian nominee so
you know it it wasn't in the cards for
2024 I appreciate all the people who
were very enthusiastic in particularly
you Tim who were always I know you were
like way in on the
DAT I appreciate that wait wait
particularly Tim P Clint Russell was
just like dying to
see I'm sorry Clint were you on this
episode I don't even oh my God hello
like Liberty lock down oh I know you
what's up buddy Gandhi didn't didn't
need to be president to change the world
like you can be he just needed to sleep
with nine-year-olds in his bed would you
consider would you consider I'm sorry
guys it's history I got to read some
more Super chats I'm sorry let's we got
we have the members only coming up a
second but I want to try and get as many
people in um uh Dr or is it Dr radmack
says Tim uh to remind you of your own
words the left has no values they're
just spewing new thing and I actually
think that's fair to say seeing a lot of
these leftists blindly just claim that
Bin Laden was right without actually
knowing what they're talking about is
maybe not absolutely because uh some of
these videos are from people who say
they're Muslim from Muslim countries and
they're surprised now that this video is
coming out or this this Letter's coming
out but some of these people are just
like dude you did not read that L well
yeah but you know but again the the
point I'm trying to make is I almost see
this as consistency on their part do you
remember like do you remember uh when
James James Lindsay like reprinted mind
comp and they agreed with it you know
what I mean like this is my point you're
right
the wokeness is the social Orthodoxy of
the liberal of the left liberal faction
right that that's it and so that means
when you know even to Jame when James
Lindsay is like well the left believes
these things and these things I'm like
no no no no they don't that's why why is
it that the same people who are you know
woke are also flying Ukrainian Flags
whatever current thing is that and and
and you know one things and one of the
things that's really kind of like uh
entertaining in a dark way is that the
debate on the left right now when you
have like kind of leftist like uh Jews
or leftist like pro-israeli types versus
leftist Pro Palestinian types is that
they've all there's so much atrophy from
like the last like 15 years that they
can't even have a debate so all they
have to do is try to out woke each other
yeah you know what I mean like the the
Jews will be like we're the oppressed
minority and then they'll be like no
we're the oppressed minority like you
should be canceled no you should be
canceled and it's like this is the only
tool they have left in their tool belt
it's really it's sad to it puts me in a
terribly challenging position to try and
make the Palestinian ARG argument
without being categorized as one of
these people because I don't have like
anything in common with them otherwise
but I think they happen to be right just
for the wrong reasons X Y and Z says you
fail to understand that Islam's goal is
to subjugate everyone to Islam it is not
a a banal Live and Let Live ideology
it's like communism you're right they
are so freaking horrible and let me tell
you something about how much better our
culture is is that the United States of
America would never try to subjugate the
rest of the world to our goals right I
mean like come on dude it's like it's so
easy just pass this blame off on some
other culture while we're doing it who's
actually taking over the world they had
the ability they tried to conquer us
it's like as we conquer all of them dude
what part of the world there are there
are a couple sections on the freaking
globe that the US Empire but I'm just
saying a couple sections on the globe
that the US Empire doesn't Dominate and
we are every single day demonizing them
trying to move in on dominating them so
I'm sorry no I'm not saying it does but
no American gets to just point the
finger over at them and say you don't
understand the nature of their ideology
sorry screw that I and I agree with uh
uh to a great degree this comment that
it is a lot like communism and it's
different because it's a religion and
communism is just people trying to steal
power communism is kind of a religion
too but sure I get your point but I mean
like one's got a god at least and one's
got scripture and but my my my thing is
and I'll say this about Israel having
power doesn't make you inherently wrong
or evil AG it's what you're doing and so
for the United States it uh I agree with
you the US is doing all of these things
it is bad it would be bad if anyone else
did it and so we shouldn't be doing it
yeah 100% but it's just like kind of a
weird thing where like it's like if you
I don't know like if you were like
taking away like kicking like a
schizophrenic person out of their house
and as you're kicking them out of their
house you're going you know that that
guy wants to take my house it's like
yeah but you're actively taking his
house like how do do you get to do that
and so I'm not even denying that yeah
there's radical islamists who would
totally love to take over the world and
take over and enforce Sharia law on the
whole world okay there's no threat of
that happening right so let's deal with
reality yep all right let's read some
more what do we have here what do we
have here um Ryan rener says Ian's
timcast coffee should be the instant
freeze dried crystals since he love
crystals so much that's funny I don't
like instant coffee though I want a low
acidity maybe coffee something like that
how would we do that like a dark roast
well there's just certain types I don't
know how they're made but certain types
of coffees are very low acidity you can
avoid the the burn I got I got to give
an honorable mention as as we do because
you were talking about you saw what
Bethany Mandel tweeted right I don't
think so she said the only I'm
paraphrasing the only reason not to Nuke
Gaza is that the Fallout would would har
oh I saw that yeah I mean there's
certainly not same thought happen and
look I mean and Lindsey Graham saying
you know turn Gaza of glass or flatten
Gau and all this stuff look there's
horrible rhetoric on all sides coming
out this saying with or without evidence
we should yeah which is really Lindy
Graham is as crazy as any jihadist as
any jihadist he's absolutely out of his
mind and he's been in power forever I
mean again and that's not to give cover
to one side to point out the other but
it's like point out how crazy both
there's crazy but you will see within
like kind of the corporate media where
there's so much attention paid in fact
people will go on and it'll just be like
they said River to the Sea what does
River to the Sea really mean to you and
then someone will be like well okay look
I mean it could mean that they think all
of Israel should be returned to the
Muslims or it could mean they want a
genocide everywhere it could but it's
like well what is flatten Gaza mean what
do turn Gaza to Glass said finish them
and what does that mean like what
exactly like how many inoc there is over
1 million kids in Gaza right now so like
what are we talking about here's a
here's a good one for you Nathan breaker
says Dave given that we've been funding
Ukraine do you think they'll be our next
enemy
well dude listen you they based off the
intro to your show you have to say yes
look look there's no question they're
already our enemy I mean they're already
are listen the the ukrainians have part
of who we've been funding are the you
want to talk about the radical
right-wing elements in the Ukrainian
forces I mean the as of and the you know
I mean this is uh you know like straight
up Neo-Nazi groups I'm not saying that's
all of Ukraine I'm not sure they're
going to exist look Ukraine forget even
our enemy cuz that is my tagline one of
the things might show is if you want to
know who our next enemy is look at who
we're funding right now well look who
there was just an article this week
saying that Ukraine were the ones who
pulled off the nordstream pipeline
bombing right now I don't know if I
believe that uh but that's a a a
terrorist attack on a European uh Ally
right so yeah this is how the cycle
always works and um by the way look at
uh it applies to Israel too funding and
propping up Hamas and now look where
they are we're here funding Israel at
the moment we had Maj noan he made a
really interesting point about this
where he said what we're essentially
doing is we are arming arming and giving
combat training and combat experience to
neo-nazis all we do all the media wants
to discuss is
radicalization and how there's going to
be some kind of far-right Uprising in
the United States look what we're
actually doing and we are literally like
arming Nazi here's the important point
though we've been doing that in the Wabi
sect of Islam forever also like the and
the point Majid was making is after the
war in Ukraine is over aav does not
disappear you still have a bunch of
neo-nazis who have combat training to be
fair uh a fair amount of them have
disappeared thanks to Vladimir Putin but
uh that's but yes and you're you know
and it's pretty funny that like you know
uh the same people who call anyone right
of Center who disagrees with them a
Neo-Nazi here who have supported this
you know propping up of the Ukrainian
side of this proxy war where make
nothing but excuses for them like I've
literally seen uh what's her name uh
Kathy uh who the one who debated Scott
Horton Kathy Kathy young and she's and
she's the most like goes after all these
right Wingers writes for like bullwark
or whatever and Scott Horton at one
point brought up like the aov Battalion
and he was like uh he goes uh he brings
up the aov Battalion and she goes I
don't want to discuss the aov Battalion
right now he's like of course you don't
course you don't you don't and then she
goes but it's so funny cuz she'll attack
any right-wing group like here in the
United States of America and she's like
yes was the group founded by a Nazi um
yes it's true but they later moved away
from that like so now watch any Trump
supporter is a Nazi but a literal
Neo-Nazi like a guy walks by with a
swastika tattoo on your neck and you're
like tattoos don't really mean that much
you know it's just it's goofy it was
incredible no it's true it's true it's
very sad but it it goes back to what you
were saying earlier and it's actually a
point I was going to make well you guys
were talking but you made it before I
could get to it which is basically that
their only assessment of morality in any
given situation is what the power
Dynamic is and so in this instance
because the Nazis in Ukraine are on the
other side of the power Dynamic they're
not actual Nazis like Nazi means in
power for whatever reason anytime any
like Nazi actually just means bad like
Nazi right-wing B bigoted homop those
words all just mean B it's also crazy
like how
one of the things that's really kind of
funny is that the big claim of the PE
look I'd say just like the majority of
the political establishment was
supporting Ukraine in this war and is
now supporting Israel in their war and
in the Ukrainian War they go Vladimir
Putin cannot take territory by War right
and then they go Israel has a right to
defend itself you're like how did they
get all their territory George W Bush's
40an slip where he was roasting
said and launching an unjust invasion of
Iraq I
mean oops you can even see in that
moment where he was like he I'm GNA go
to hell I got I got I got one last one
for you that will uh light a fire under
you before we go all right Lea says
bottom line the modern West is the
primary force which prevents The Rebirth
of the rashidan caliphate people like
ubl will never forgive the West for that
and the West should never seek
forgiveness for this the West must keep
the caliphate down at all costs okay
well then here would be a good idea list
well listen if you if the idea is to
keep the caliphate down at all costs may
I humbly suggest a policy of not funding
them of not funding arming training and
propping them up which by the way is
what we did not just in 1979 and 1980 to
try to take out the Soviets in
Afghanistan right we funded the
mujahadin the precursor to Al-Qaeda but
that and this really started with the
George W Bush Administration and in
around 2006 after their dumbass war in
Iraq led to this uh led to this uh you
know the Shiites taking full control in
in Iran and then they realized they had
to do the redirect and start siding with
the Sunni radicals but then under Barack
Obama in Libya in Syria in Yemen he
sided with Al-Qaeda directly funded
Al-Qaeda and Isis in Syria that's what
led to the caliphate so look if you want
to sit here say the biggest threat is
the Islamic caliphate okay why did it
happen it happened because we overthrew
Saddam Hussein who was a bulwark against
it we overthrew mmar Gaddafi who was a
bullwark against it we tried to
overthrow bash Bashar al- Assad who was
a bullwark against it right we did
everything and then directly funded them
so how about we stop doing that if
you're so concerned how about doesn't
fund Hamas how about we're going to go
to S uh we're going to go to the members
only show so go to
timcast.net on top of everything it's
been so hard not swearing so hard huh so
again
timcast.net
by you Dave's latest hour is the best
work he's ever done make sure you go see
him thank at Liberty lock Twitter uh
yeah subscribe follow do all that uh
liberty lockdown is the show Please
Subscribe follow it on YouTube Rumble
everywhere else Tower gang on Wednesdays
it's out of it's insane maybe don't
subscribe whatever uh and then uh the
best political show.com or we are change
all one word on rumber Rumble and
YouTube with Luca Kowski we're going to
have on Jackson Hinkle on Sunday night
do not miss it my name is Sheamus coglin
I have a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes I make animated political cartoons
please go on over there the new cartoon
is is doing decently well people are
really laughing at it I enjoyed it a lot
if you see it and you like it and you
want to support what I do become a
member at Freedom tunes.com you'll get
an extra cartoon each week and we are
also launching a behind the scenes
podcast that I think you'll enjoy if
you're a fan and uh follow me at Ian
Crossland on the internet so anywhere
pretty much every day at 1:00 I'll do an
interview with somebody cool I talked to
Forest Cooper today went for like two
and a half hours talking about
Battlefield tactics and so much more the
philosophy of combat and the basically
the philosophy of violence it was very
very interesting also it was
invigorating to be in the room with two
future American Presidents I'll let you
guys decide who those two people are
going to
be and um me and Tim Tim always always
happy to be here just Sheamus alone on a
hill and uh I'm surge.com I've been
hanging out in the corner watching you
guys go at it it's been fun as always uh
yeah cheers see you guys in the after
show we'll see yall at Tim cast.com in a
few minutes thanks for hanging
out